MonkaW!
Untertitelung des ZDF, 2020
Okay, Quade, hallo?
Alter, ich laber die ganze Zeit schon.
Ich wunder mich schon.
Warum?
Keine Ahnung, was das wieder ist.
Ja, also, was ich gesagt hab, ist,
ich hab davon heute Morgen eine Tüte gefuttert.
Äh.
Ich muss gleich wieder einschalten.
Ich habe heute Morgen so eine Tüte gegessen hier.
Nein, wir removen das nicht.
Wir schalten U-Block gleich wieder ein.
Guck, nur 569 Kalorien pro Tüte.
Prime Sub, excellent.
Dazu kann ich nur sagen.
Exzellente Subscriptions.
Habe ich mir gedacht, komm, ich gehe nachher eh eine Runde Fahrrad fahren.
Da kann man sich morgens zum Frühstück auch mal zwei Toastbrote plus extra 569 Kalorien reinhauen.
Easy.
Pippo Fat Time.
Ist gar nicht, bin ich heute früher oder später als sonst?
Ganz leicht, ja.
Ich muss das mal kurz machen hier.
damit U-Block Origin wieder funzt
in
ähm
in meinem Chromium
das muss auf Disabled
das hier muss auch auf Disabled
und das hier muss wieder auf Enabled
jetzt restarten wir
starte das verdammte Spiel
so und jetzt haben wir wieder UBlock Origin am Start. Nice!
hier kriegen wir Last of Us Werbung okay aber sollten wir eigentlich nicht. Nice!
Excellent! Da sind wir wieder mit UBlock Origin
activated! Leider funzt das nur noch bis Chromium 1.33 oder so und dann ist das
vorbei dann wird das ja komplett raus gepatcht
warum niemand ins handwerk will naja weil die bedingungen mit meisten betrieben
nicht soll ich geil sind
Und weil ich glaube im Handwerk so diese Boomer Chef Geschichte noch krasser ist als überall
anders auch.
Wow, was ist das?
Warum macht mein Handy komische Geräusche?
Ah, Message.
Hab ich mir gedacht.
Hast du das Drama mit den CVE Support?
Ne, was denn?
Das kenne ich nicht.
Dankeschön für den Sub.
Exzellente Subscriptions, Leute. Dankeschön.
Ne.
Was war da schon wieder?
Ich hab, ich hab erstaunlich wenig
Drama mitbekommen.
Ich hab, ich hab nur
mitbekommen, dass die Freundin von
Tanzverbot fremdgegangen ist.
Unfreiwillig
hab ich das mitbekommen, weil das jemand auf
Twitter repostet oder
retweetet hat. Sorry, sorry, Leute.
X, formerly known as
Twitter. Ja.
Ansonsten habe ich wenig Drama mitbekommen.
Oder alternativ kann es auch sein, dass es einfach zu viel Drama war und ich das schon komplett nicht mehr bei mir im Kopf behalte.
Trump meinte, CVEs sind... Was hat das... Was hat Vogue mit CVE zu tun?
Synology ist richtig am Reinscheißen. Das habe ich wirklich gekriegt.
Synology will jetzt keine Festplatten einfach mehr so unterstützen, die nicht Synology zertifiziert sind, sozusagen
CVN am 15. Bericht, dass sie am 16. kommen, jetzt
Oh
Ja gut, es gibt ja noch, gibt ja glücklicherweise noch mehr Stellen, oder?
Ansonsten wäre das ziemlich kacke
Den Zusammenhang zwischen
CVEs und CVEs in Vogue
Kann ich jetzt nicht so herstellen
Die spinnen eh alle
Ich mach mal kurz
Package Updates
Die spinnen eh alle Leute, wisst ihr was
Egal welche Seite
Die haben alle den übelsten Dachschaden
Für die einen ist alles Nazi
für die anderen ist alles woke, für die anderen ist alles irgendwie gut Mensch.
Du kannst das mittlerweile echt komplett in die Tonne kloppen.
Und ich habe den Eindruck, die meisten Leute beteiligen sich einfach gar nicht daran.
Deswegen denkt man, dass das immer viel mehr sind, als es eigentlich der Fall ist.
Die meisten Leute wollen einfach nur mit ihrem Daily Business klarkommen,
haben überhaupt keinen Bock auf den ganzen Scheiß.
Mittlerweile sind wir ja schon bei dem Punkt angelangt,
dass aktiv also wie soll ich sagen dass nichts zu sagen von allen seiten ja schon als zustimmung
für die andere seite interpretiert wird aber die meisten leute wollen einfach nur ihre ruhe
und haben keinen bock auf den ganzen scheiß ist halt eine sparmaßnahme ich wusste ich wusste
ehrlich gesagt wusste ich gar nicht dass das irgendeine usa gesponserte gesache ist
und das mit Synology
das fuckt mich auch ab
weiß ich ob ihr das gesehen habt
unerlaubte Festplatten
man muss sich mal das Wort auf der Zunge zergehen lassen
es gibt unerlaubte Festplatten
in einem NAS
wo man sich denkt, ist ein NAS nicht eigentlich genau dafür da
Festplatten aufzunehmen
und was ich jetzt nicht so genau checke ist was sein ology damit vorhat also ja mehr geld verdienen
das ist mir das ist es ist mir auch klar aber ich bin mir nicht sicher ob das so funktioniert
wie die sich das vorstellen, ob da irgendein
Keck-Wee-Business-Mensch gesagt hat,
oh geil, wir brauchen Van-Horloggen
bei unserem Nas,
das ist ganz wichtig,
weil, ganz im Ernst,
vielleicht täusche ich mich da ja auch, ja,
aber,
also,
mein Eindruck von Synology ist,
das Gefühl,
jeder Zweite daheim,
übertrieben gesagt, jetzt so ein Synology-Ding stehen hat,
ich hab keins bei mir daheim stehen,
aber viele Leute haben
1 daheim stehen. Umgedreht,
irgendwie im Business,
Enterprise Umfeld,
jetzt beispielsweise in irgendeinem
Rechenzentrum oder so, hab ich noch
nie ein Synology Gerät
hängen sehen. Noch nie. Habt ihr das schon mal?
Habt ihr das schon mal irgendwie? Die haben
welche. Ich hab extra
nachgeguckt, ja. Also Synology
hat
19, ja, Bässe.
Synology hat 19 Zoll
Rack-Bauweise-Dinger.
Aber ich habe noch nie irgendwo eins gesehen.
Es kann sein, ich meine, ich war auch schon eine Weile nicht mehr im Rechenzentrum.
Vielleicht sind die Dinger ja mittlerweile überall.
Aber wenn ich an Rechenzentrum-Storage denke,
dann denke ich zum größten Teil erstmal an die ollen IBM-Dinger
und irgendwelche NetApp-Sachen, wenn es teuer sein muss.
Was ist denn so?
Chat, was ist so typisches Rechenzentrum
Storage Zeug?
Also
ich denke zumindest
von Dell
gibt es auch Storage
aber ich denke
auf jeden Fall nicht unbedingt jetzt an
Synology
also
ich frage mich halt
wer, also was da
das Ziel ist, weil
wenn man jetzt so Richtung Business Enterprise
Umfeld gehen will, da ist es ja gang und
gebe, dass alles und
jede Schraube zertifiziert sein muss.
Ich meine, zertifizierte Festplatten habe ich jetzt noch nicht gehört,
aber bei professionellen Storage
Systemen ist es eher so, dass
du meistens gar nicht einfach mal hingehst und irgendwie
random da was austauscht, du kriegst die
Sachen halt einfach fertig
geliefert.
Ich muss auch ehrlich sagen, ich weiß gar nicht,
ich überlege gerade, ich glaube, ich habe es
noch nie gesehen, dass bei
einem, sagen wir mal so,
als Komplettpaket gekauftem
Storage-System mal irgendwie
einzelne Festplatten ausgetauscht wurden.
Also ich kann mich noch dran erinnern,
beim alten Arbeitgeber hatten wir
drei größere IBM-Storages.
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob es diese Dinger noch gibt.
Ja doch.
Gibt es immer noch.
Glaube ich zumindest.
Solche Teile
waren das, genau.
Ja.
Drei größere Storages davon.
Und ich kann mich nicht daran erinnern, dass da jemals irgendwie eine Festplatte ausgetauscht wurde.
Im Zweifelsfall wurde da wahrscheinlich ein ganzer Einschub einfach ausgetauscht, wenn das kaputt war.
Hab da nie einen wirklich dran rumbasteln sehen.
Also im Business Enterprise Umfeld ist es ja relativ normal, dass jeder Scheiß zertifiziert ist.
Aber nachdem ich Zynology da überhaupt nicht sehe, frage ich mich, was der Sinn und Zweck davon sein soll.
Weil du kriegst doch nicht die 0815 Casual-Leute daheim dazu, sich jetzt auch noch neben einem teuren Nass noch mal einen Satz neuer Festplatten zu kaufen.
naja gut aber ich kann mir nicht vorstellen dass das klappt und ich glaube auch eher dass
seine leute da wahrscheinlich relativ schnell wieder zurückrudern wird gucken wir mal im
zweifelsfall gibt es wieder irgendwelche patches oder hacks oder sonst was wie man das doch wieder
mit x-beliebigen Festplatten
benutzen kann. Ich frage mich gerade,
was ist denn aus
diesem, aus dieser
Synology, wie hießen das nochmal?
Xpenology oder so?
Was ist denn
daraus geworden? Gibt es das eigentlich noch?
Diese Synology OS
für
zum Selbstinstallieren?
Ich glaube, das gibt es noch, oder?
Oder war das nicht so, dass das mit den neuen Versionen nicht mehr funktioniert?
Download Links Below, ah ja, okay, alles klar.
Scheint es doch nicht mehr so zu geben.
Die 0815 User wollen ihre alten Festplatten da reinhängen und den Kram verwenden.
Guck mal Leute die sich ein NAS daheim kaufen, die sind zumindest semi technik interessiert.
Alle anderen kaufen sich einen Microsoft Cloud Account und laden das da 3 Tage lang hoch.
Also pro Gigabyte sind Festplatten immer noch deutlich günstiger als SSDs.
Umfrage, wer hat eine NAS?
Ist die Frage, was du als NAS definierst, so ein fertiges Ding, was man als NAS kauft?
oder zählt auch was wo man linux drauf installiert hat und drei festplatten
dranhängen mit einem netzwerklaufwerk
ja aber es ist trotzdem bescheuert dass das überhaupt auf die dass sie überhaupt
auf die idee kommen
ich habe jetzt neues handy von der arbeit gekriegt das hat usb c
das bringt meine ganze ladedings hier durcheinander weil ich habe zwei
lightning stecker bisher hier gehabt und ein usb stecker den usb stecker und
mikro usb mikro usb und usb habe ich bisher nur für kopfhörer verwendet und
die lightnings immer für die iphones aber jetzt hat das neue iphone auch ein
usb c jetzt komme ich nicht mehr hin neues irgendwie neues usb stecker usb
stecker
Aber ein schönes hat's, über kurz oder lang wird's nur noch USB-C sein.
Was ich denke in den nächsten 5 Jahren ist es durch, da sind alle meine Geräte nur noch
USB-C.
Hast du den neuen China-Chinesen-Stecker gesehen?
Ne?
Würdest du sagen, dass man in 90% der Fälle mit einem simplen Docker-Compose-File besser
fällt als mit einem Kubernetes-Cluster?
also prinzipiell würde ich sagen ja aber es kommt natürlich immer darauf an was
man haben will für viele sachen muss man es auch gar nicht groß
vercontainerisieren je nachdem was wir machen will also wenn du einfach nur
sagen wir jetzt mal statischen web content irgendwo anzeigen willst dann
muss das nicht mal irgendwie verkauft was willst du groß verkonzentrieren
jlo danke für den sub
es gab ja früher gab es noch doch erst oder wie das heißt das gibt es glaube
ich aber nicht mehr das war glaube ich auf swan basis das
ist ja auf dated overrated sie betet mittlerweile
china entwickelt eigene hdmi alter gpm
china's gp
ich habe in chrome kann er blocker
möchte ich muss es hier aufmachen
china entwickelt eigen hdmi alternative
gpm china china es gibt hier mehr als
flotte als einer wahl für
Aha
GPMI läuft auch über USB Typ C
Gucken wir mal, was die Chinesen so treiben
Würdest du bei neuen Projekten eher OpenTOFU oder eher Terraform benutzen?
Habe ich mir noch keine Gedanken drüber gemacht
So Bauchgefühl sagt mir eher Open Tofu, aber ich kann es dir nicht sagen.
Da habe ich mir noch wenig Gedanken drüber gemacht bisher.
Ich weiß auch gar nicht, inwieweit die mittlerweile auseinander liegen, Terraform und Open Tofu.
Also als die neu waren, haben die ja gesagt, die portieren den ganzen Kram von Terraform rüber, sodass das möglichst kompatibel bleibt.
Ich habe aber keine Ahnung, wie das sich entwickelt hat.
Also ich weiß nicht, wie gut Open Tofu und Terraform mittlerweile, wie einheitlich die noch sind
Also in meinem Auto gibt es ja auch so ein Handschuhfach quasi in der Mitte
Wo man sein Handy reinschmeißen kann
Und da wird das auch kabellos geladen
Aber das benutze ich nie, ich schließe immer Kabel an
So, ich wollte eigentlich
OS-Update machen
Hier vergessen, Passwort einzutippen
Was wird geupdatet?
Visual Studio Code und Candy-Icons
Aha
Gucken wir mal, ob wir, oh, das Jetbrains-Zeug
Will auch geupdatet werden
MonkHS für mehr
C++, Leute
Updaten wir
Das wird jetzt auf jeden Fall ein bisschen
ruckeln aber nur in der vm das nicht schlimm weil die dinger brauchen massig cpu beim upgrade weil
die downloaden dann wird erstmal ein tag entpackt und sechs mal sachen entpacken parallel oder fünf
mal da wird gleich 100 prozent cpu spike geben jet brains jetzt mit ei die haben doch die ganze zeit
schon auch so ein lokales ei model drin was ich ganz praktisch finde irgendwelche online
ein ei sachen beim programmieren weiß ich nicht kann man sich jetzt darüber streiten ist also mir
geht es zum größten teil auf den sack aber das lokale model was chat brains hat es ist ganz
ist ganz okay also wird bekommt das sony die preise in der eu anzieht um die urse also direkt
gehört von sony habe ich nicht aber es wundert mich nicht und das wird mit sony sicherlich auch
nicht dass der einzige laden sein
gestern war ich insgesamt ich war sieben kilometer oder ein bisschen siebeneinhalb
kilometer rennen siebeneinhalb kilometer noch mal spazieren morgens und dann
nochmal 8 km mittags wandern quasi. Merkst du heute noch in den Beinen, also so 22, 23
km am Tag und davon ein Drittel gerannt ist dann doch, das merkt man einen Tag später
noch. Deswegen gehe ich heute auch lieber eine Runde Fahrrad fahren als noch eine Runde
rennen, weil es echt gutes Wetter. Ich habe ja noch Windows 10 hier am Start,
auf dem zweiten Rechner, also quasi hier
auf der linken Seite, was ihr jetzt nicht seht.
Und da ist auf einmal ein Autopilot-Button
erschienen, unten links. Ich klicke da mal drauf.
Mal gucken, was jetzt passiert.
Ja, geht
Message Copilot auf.
Nicht Autopilot, Copilot.
Das ist einfach random. Einfach random aufgeploppt.
Also Microsoft
erschlägt einen ja wirklich mit
AI-Gedöns.
dazu fällt mir dazu fällt mir nur ein sekunde wo wir gerade dabei sind
Also Microsoft ist da wirklich sehr offensiv auch mit ihrer AI-Geschichte.
Du wirst auf jeder Microsoft-Veranstaltung zugeschwätzt mit AI.
Alter, was wird mir hier wieder empfohlen?
Magst du das Ding erinnern?
ppo ai das bräuchten wir mal gibt es da schon ppo ai das brauchen wir hier gibt es nicht
ja wurdest du auch zugetextet mit ai ai ai ai ai
Guck mal, Update ist fertig.
Nice.
Exzellent.
Dann haben wir jetzt alles geupdatet.
Dann können wir jetzt reboot.
Müssen wir das mal aliasen auf reboot.
So, ja.
Dann gucken wir mal, was auf Shithub so trendet heute.
Wahrscheinlich AI.
Wenn ich raten müsste.
Trendet wieder 80% AI.
The Shave Champ.
Da.
Tag.
Lass uns doch mal schauen, was
Trending Repositories
für die Week sind.
AI.
ach nee cvr okay ja weil abschalten also ei ei ei ei ei ei ei ei ei ei ei ei ei ei
keine ahnung nicht auch nicht
keine ahnung michael nicht
Was ist das?
Cap.
Machst du eigentlich noch YouTube-Videos?
Ja.
Ich habe aber nicht gesagt,
in welchem Intervall.
Cap ist
Open Source Alternative to Loom.
Ich habe von Loom noch nie was gehört.
Video Messaging Tool allows you to record, edit and share videos in seconds.
Okay.
Also damit kann man im Endeffekt einfach nur Screen-Dings-Zeug aufnehmen.
Ach, es gibt es natürlich nicht für Linux.
Super.
macOS und Windows.
Ja, geil.
Gucken wir mal.
Arch Linux Cap.
Okay, nee, finden wir das nicht.
Downloads.
Nope.
Ja dann.
Ansonsten.
Okay, da sehen wir mal ganz aktuell, was trennt heute.
AI, AI, AI, AI.
Ne, doch nicht. Das gleiche.
Panel.
Alle Sigma-Chats.
naja
hab ich irgendwie auch schon
spannendere Wochen erlebt
das Jahr des Linux-Desktops
ja, eindeutig
Leute, wenn das Jahr
des Linux-Desktops dann endlich
anbricht, dieses Jahr oder nächstes Jahr
meinte das mit wailand oder mit x ist
also meinte wailand funktioniert dann halbwegs normal wenn das ja das linux desktops ist
ist klar kann ich mir nämlich nicht vorstellen dass wailand dann ordentlich funktioniert
weil jedes mal über die letzten jahre wo ich mir weil angeguckt habe hat es nicht richtig
funktioniert und jetzt nutzen ja schon wählen per default ja federer auch bei
Bei Ubuntu weiß ich es doch.
Doch, ich glaube die auch, ja.
Das kann durchaus an X liegen.
Ich glaube, es wird mal wieder Zeit, dass wir das ausprobieren.
Aber die letzten Male gab es eigentlich jedes Mal so große Probleme mit Wayland.
Dass ich es nicht verwenden wollte.
Ich meine, das beste Beispiel war...
Wobei das ja mittlerweile gefixt haben, dass wenn du das in einer VM betreibst, dass dann der Screen einfach nicht refresht.
Du hast dann 0 FPS.
Es stürzt nicht ab oder so.
Du hast einfach wirklich legit 0 FPS.
Du siehst halt nichts.
Das haben sie ja wohl mittlerweile gefixt, aber ich bin mal gespannt, wie gut das mittlerweile in einer VM funktioniert.
Weil für mich ist das wichtig.
Solange ich nicht mein Linux auf dem zweiten Desktop haben kann, kann ich meinen Rechner nicht gescheit verwenden.
und dementsprechend, solange das mit Wayland nicht geht,
ordentlich, werde ich auch nicht Wayland verwenden.
Also das war eine Kombination mit Hyperland.
Keine Ahnung, ob das vielleicht mit Gnome besser funktioniert.
Kann durchaus sein.
Mal gespannt.
Wisst ihr, was mir ja noch fehlt?
Die Möglichkeit, aber
das werden wir bei Forever nicht mehr erleben,
weil Forever gefühlt an Forever Workstation,
die machen da ja nichts mehr dran.
Da gibt es ab und zu neue Versionen, aber es tut sich
irgendwie so gut wie nichts.
Die könnten mal gucken, ob sie es nicht vielleicht noch auf die
Reihe kriegen, dass
Grafikkarten-Paththrough ordentlich funktioniert
auf dem Desktop.
Weil ich meine unter Linux funktioniert das ja auch
Das geht bestimmt unter Windows auch
Wenn man sich Mühe gibt
Aber
Vor allem macht der da überhaupt keine Anstalten
Irgendwas an vor allem bei Workstation zu ändern
Ich meine das ist immer noch
Die beste Desktop-Virtualisierung die wir haben
Unter Windows
Jetzt kommt mir keiner mit Hyper-V oder irgendwie sowas
Ich weiß noch nicht
Ob Hyper-V unter Windows 11 überhaupt
Gescheit funktioniert mit grafischer Ausgabe
haben wir eigentlich schon
reboot, ja haben wir, wir haben reboot
ich glaube schon 3 mal oder so
reboot
aber ich kann mal ein paar Fenster
zumachen hier
ach wobei
Man könnte durchaus mal ein paar Fenster zumachen, glaube ich
Guck mal hier, das sind so viele Fenster
Chat, seid ihr jetzt eigentlich auch schon umgestiegen von Chrome auf Firefox oder Brave oder Vivaldi oder so?
seit Chrome
ihre Geschichte mit Manifest V3
und keine Adblocker oder keine
gescheiten Adblocker mehr
wahrgemacht hat.
Nie weg gewesen von Firefox.
Ich auch nicht.
Ich war nie richtig weg von Firefox.
Ich benutze Firefox
seit...
Das ist jetzt kein Witz.
seit es nicht Firefox hieß, benutze ich
Firefox schon. Weil Firefox hieß
früher nicht Firefox. Weiß noch jemand,
wie Firefox früher hieß?
Wer ist
noch so oldschool, ohne zu googeln?
Und weiß noch, wie
Firefox... Firebird,
genau. Ja, Phoenix
habe ich nicht mehr benutzt. Firebird
Browser hieß der ursprünglich mal, ja.
Ich weiß nicht, warum sie sich umbenannt haben.
Vielleicht um nicht in Konflikt mit
Gab es nicht Firebird als Datenbank?
Ja ne, ich glaube das ist
War das nicht IBM?
Ne, das war Firebase
Ne, aber Firebird
Datenbank gab es glaube ich auch
Okay
Freies Datenbank
Es ist der Ableger
das war dann kommt kautka bohlen war das mal okay die haben sie aber auch die haben sich von von
ganz gut in beschissen benannt umbenannt oder ich war in bohlen konnte man sich merken code
geht auch noch irgendwie und jetzt heißt es im barcadero niemand kann das merken
gab es nicht auch noch sei base oder sowas wieso gab es doch auch noch wie hat man das
geschrieben oder sei es sei base es war es ab genau war das nicht so und jetzt
jetzt jetzt kann sein dass ich komplett mist erzähle ist nicht so dass sql server
ein Sybase Fork ist?
War das nicht irgendwie so?
Oder
Oder bring ich das jetzt gerade ganz durcheinander?
Eier!
Genau!
Hier, Sybase, genau!
War doch irgendwie was in der Richtung.
Ja.
Habe ich doch richtig in Erinnerung.
Real Life.
Ja dann.
GLHF.
Borland Bilder C++ gelernt.
Das kenne ich auch noch.
Aus der Berufsschule.
Kennt das Ding noch jemand?
Borland C++ Bilder.
Moment, das gibt es immer noch? Das verkaufen die immer noch?
Gibt es denn nicht mal einen Screenshot zu?
Kennt das noch jemand?
Hat ein bisschen was von Whistle Basic 6.
habe ich euch mal erzählt dass ich ein wish basic programmierkurs wie ich jung war besucht habe an
der volkshochschule in hanau ein wish basic programmierkurs und da waren alles so kinders
in meinem alter das dürfte so 1998 um gewesen sein das heißt da war ich 14 und wir haben dann
am ende half-life gespielt auf den rechner dort die alle keinen bock die
an alle keinen bock was zu programmieren wir haben dann einfach auf half-life auf
cds mitgebracht und der half-life gespielt
Ja, ich kann mich selbst kaum dran erinnern, aber es war echt so...
Ich werde dieses Jahr 41, könnt ihr euch das vorstellen?
Heck, wait!
Wir haben nicht wirklich einen Old-Emote, aber...
Delphi?
Also da habe ich
einen Bogen drum gemacht, um
Delphi und Turbo Pascal und so was.
Fragst du dich manchmal, wie wohl das Leben
von denen aus diesem Bewerbungstraining
bisher gelaufen ist? Ich weiß nicht, was
du meinst.
ja wupp aul sowas hatten wir mal gibt es doch das geht es immer noch aber aus irgendwelchen
gründen habe ich das nicht als im auto drin dafür habe ich ein viel viel wichtigeres im
mode renne kek w javascript muss aber sagen eigentlich müsste es eher kek wc
plus plus sein weil im vergleich zu javascript verschlechtert sich das immer
weiter und javascript verbessert sich die letzten jahre über eigentlich weiter
wir bräuchten ein kek wc plus plus gremium
ich finde es zu go zum größten teil ganz angenehm
da gibt es ein paar sachen die mir in go auf den keks gehen zum beispiel dieser extreme hang zu
minimalistischen das ist schon wieder keinen sinn macht zum beispiel wie warum sollte man ordentlich
eine liste filtern können macht auch drei nested schleifen ist doch viel expliziter und so was ist
der Go-Weg,
das so zu machen.
Lieber 50 nested Schleifen, anstatt
ein paar sinnvolle Sachen eingebaut.
Also manche Sachen geben mir ein Go auf den Keks,
aber es ist nichts im Vergleich
zu dem, was mir an C++ beispielsweise
auf den Keks geht.
C++ ist ja wirklich die Ausgeburt der Hölle
an Sachen, die einem auf den Sack gehen.
Bei Go kann ich so gut wie mit allem leben.
Wenn auch ein paar Sachen echt nicht schön sind.
dass der drei varianten hast wieder variabel anlegst zum beispiel dass die dass das die
teilweise in go zu minimalistisch sind wie gesagt macht lieber drei nesten schleifen anstatt irgendwie
mal ordentlich was filtern zu können und wenn ich jetzt ein bisschen darüber nachdenke fallen
wir bestimmt noch die einen oder anderen sachen ein ja go generics sind auch ein bisschen wird
champ und wenn ich go bastel fällt mir noch mehr ein was mir an go ja die go
standard library ist teilweise auch sehr merkwürdig in der handhabung
beispielsweise die ganze timing geschichte daytime sachen die sind also
dass das ist in go mag wird teilweise richtig gute sachen aber auch
gleichzeitig richtig schlechte sachen in einem also die daytime library ist ein
gutes beispiel ist auf der einen seite richtig gut auf der anderen seite
richtig kacke aber ich mache zu selten was im go um jetzt da top aktuelle
detaillierte beispiele zu haben ich immer wenn ich was in go mach merke ich
halt so die sache die mir auf den keks geht aber im großen und ganzen ist go
nicht schlecht man ist verwöhnt von sich von link in
sich ab das stimmt wohl ja dankeschön max keck wie business exzellente
subscription aber go kann sachen besser als jede andere programmiersprache
beziehungsweise jedes jede andere die proklamiert ist jetzt vielleicht nicht
so ganz wie nennt man das besser als jede andere
so gebung oder jeder jede besser als jedes andere ökosystem nennen wir es mal
so ja das trifft es eigentlich ganz gut und zwar das ist es wenn es um möglichst
einfache selbst self content bayerisch geht mit möglichst wenig die pendels
drumherum ist das beste was es gibt es gibt keine andere kein anderes ökosystem
keine andere Sprache, wo es so einfach ist, Binaries zu generieren, die einfach überall laufen
und so wenig Abhängigkeiten haben wie möglich wie in Go.
Ich meine, in Go kannst du auf jedem x-beliebigen System ein Go-Binary erzeugen,
was auf jedem anderen x-beliebigen Linux-System läuft.
also wenn du cgo ausschaltet und cgo brauchen die meisten ja nicht
also das gibt es in keiner anderen programmier sprache so gut wie in go und nachdem die ganzen
binaries auch keinerlei abhängigkeit haben kann man sie das ganze auch in
konnten in den minimalsten container aller zeiten packen so ein go bei
einem es funktioniert ja das ist es ist so ziemlich jede andere
programmiersprache wenn es ums kostkompilen geht oder um das ja
ausführen auf älteren us version ist abfakt gegenüber go
Man ist da sehr verwöhnt von Go.
Du sagst einfach, im Endeffekt kannst du C-Go, genau, sowas hier kannst du sagen.
So, hier.
Oder machen wir es mal anders hier.
Du baust das Ding so, deine Go-Anwendung.
Und das Ding läuft auf jedem x86-System mit Linux drauf seit Kernel 2638.
Also du kannst in GoBinary hier jetzt bauen auf meiner top aktuellen Arch Linux Kiste und kopieren auf Linux von vor 15 Jahren und es läuft einfach.
Das geht in keiner anderen Programmiersprache so gut und so einfach wie in Go.
Ich würde sogar so weit gehen, mir fällt jetzt so spontan keine andere Sprache ein, wo das überhaupt so funktioniert.
Selbst mit ein bisschen Aufwand drumherum.
es ist immer es ist immer abfakt immer ein riesen akt in allen anderen sprachen in go ist das easy
und das schöne ist dass du bei go binaries noch nicht mal wieder 1000 dependencies installieren
muss dann nicht funktionieren einfach also das muss man echt sagen wenn es darum geht deswegen
ist glaube ich auch go es ist nur noch können 32 echt nicht mal 26 38 für was ja mach mal aus
perl mit einem self content binary was rückwirkend auf allen linux systemen läuft da glaube ich nicht
dass du das überhaupt hinkriegst du kannst höchstens ein perl skript ausführen wenn du
auch darauf aufpasst dass das kompatibel ist zudem uralt perl vor 15 jahren in der hoffnung
dass perl standardmäßig drauf ist ja aber ansonsten keine chance zumindest nicht mal
ansatzweise so gut wie in go also es gibt noch ein paar andere sprachen dann geht das ganz
brauchbar reine command line tools mit rust und gegen musel c library geht auch noch ganz gut
aber trotzdem da ist man einfach verwöhnt go binary erzeugt auf irgendein x beliebiges linux
system kopiert geht das mit keiner anderen programm ihr sprache alles andere ist richtig
abfakt so lass uns mal schauen was kann man uns heute auf youtube angucken was
das der durchschnittliche linkedin user day in the life ok zwei minuten 25 das
gucken wir uns jetzt
das gucken wir uns jetzt an das letzte mal haben wir uns ja schon angeguckt
warum LinkedIn so cringe ist.
Dann lassen wir uns jetzt mal erklären, was der durchschnittliche LinkedIn-User so daily in seinem Leben macht.
Ob er wieder, wie war das, humbled and proud ist?
War klar, dass das kommt.
Hmm, I want something that's outside the box.
Let's leverage some blue sky thinking
and really work towards a unique deliverable.
Um, we have a cappuccino?
Deliverable ist auch so ein ekliges Marketing,
äh, ekliger Marketingbegriff.
Das ist, wenn du auf YouTube im Influencer-Business unterwegs bist
und mit irgendwelchen Marketingagenturen schreibst,
was ich glücklicherweise schon, ich ignoriere das einfach alles
und ich mache ja eh gerade nichts auf YouTube.
Dann ist Deliverables so ein Lieblingswort von denen.
Das Schlimmste, die reden ja wirklich so.
Kannst du das mal genauer beschreiben?
Ja, ich bin stolz und stolz darauf, dass er...
Du hast es richtig gemacht, Beck!
... mein Abend verabschiedet.
Als ich nach Hause kam, hat er seine körperliche Kompetenz genutzt,
seine physische Kraft, und mir einige schreckliche Gefühle
über die Dinge, die er mir tun würde, wenn ich nicht anrufe.
Das hat mich dazu gebracht, meine Karte wieder zu distribuieren.
Als es in seiner Behandlung war, hat er sich entschieden, zu schlagen.
Okay, also war es ein Verbrechen?
Das ist ein interessantes Punkt der Sicht. Ich freue mich wirklich auf deine Ansichten.
Now, mind if I share my three secrets to writing police reports that convert seven times more?
I'm starting to think you're making all of this up just to sell me your services.
So, what do you like to do?
You raise an interesting question.
I'm humbled and proud to announce...
You know what? I can't do this anymore.
Can't do what?
This whole corporate LinkedIn being all professional thing.
I don't know why I do it.
I'm so f***ing tired of talking about B2B sales 24x7.
LinkedIn ist cringe.
I know that.
Humble and proud, they're literally opposites.
That phrase makes zero sense.
F*** this. I'm done.
Love this perspective.
Here's what it taught me about B2B-Sales.
Ja, die reden ja wirklich so.
Wo ich gerade eine Sache wiedererkannt habe,
wo er gesagt hat, we synergize oder sowas.
Da ist mir aufgefallen, dass ich ja auch mal sowas gepostet habe auf Twitter,
wie man IT-Business-Sprache,
mal gucken, wie gut das im Jahr
2025 noch passt,
das ist ein bisschen älter.
Aber seht ihr, Synergieeffekte nutzen
war damals schon angesagt.
Wir nehmen das mit,
ist ja glaube ich der Klassiker, oder?
So ziemlich in jedem Meeting, wenn es
darum geht, wie
sieht es damit jetzt aus oder sonst wie,
da gibt es zwei Sachen, die gesagt werden.
Und zwei, wir nehmen das mit oder
sind wir dran?
Bin dran ist so
Jetzt nehme ich die zweithäufigste Sache.
Nehmen wir mit.
Nachgeschärft.
Das muss ich sagen, das wird nicht mehr so oft verwendet.
Das war in meiner alten Firma total oft,
dass die gesagt haben, wird nachgeschärft.
Fireship, ja, welches?
Welches denn?
Welches der 1000 AI-Videos?
Also nachgeschärft benutzen die bei mir in der neuen Firma selten.
In der alten, wo ich gearbeitet habe, war nachgeschärft so das da.
Und also diese zwei Sachen kamen bei mir in der alten Firma gefühlt auf jedem zweiten Meeting vor.
So nach dem Motto, wie ist das Scope oder ist das im Scope oder sowas in der Richtung und das wird nachgeschärft.
Ja, T-Shirt-Größe hatten wir auch, das ist in der neuen Firma auch nicht mehr.
Das ist in der neuen Firma immer noch so, das ist in der neuen Firma auch noch so.
Das teilweise, das auf jeden Fall immer noch und Synergie-Effekte nutzen auch noch.
Oh, was ist das neue Fire-Ship-Video? Was gibt es denn hier?
Oh ne, ich kann... Leute, ich halte es nicht mehr aus, der macht nur noch AI-Videos.
Du bist nicht der Einzige, der sich das gefragt hat.
In der alten Firma habe ich mich das auch gefragt.
Ich war ja da regelmäßig auf so einem Cap in der alten Firma.
Wisst ihr, was ein Cap ist?
Damit ist kein Taxi gemeint.
Wer von euch, Chatge...
Itilspeak.
Wer weiß, was ein Cap ist?
Jetzt bin ich aber enttäuscht, Chat
Change Advisor, endlich
Wenigstens, wenigstens
Okay
Wenigstens einer, der hier im Corporate Speak unterwegs ist
Das ist ein Change Advisory Board
Im Prinzip ist das so eine Wartungsarbeitenrunde
Könnte man das auf Deutsch sagen
Also da erzählen alle, was denn demnächst so für Changes anstehen
Was dann wie gemacht wird und sowas
und da war das auch immer so
dass dann so ging es ja wir machen
das und das und das und das und
ähm
ja genau
da hat dann irgendwie einer erzählt ja wir machen dann
Wartungsarbeiten heute Nacht keine Ahnung
an der Telefonanlage
und da kam dann irgendjemand
hat gesagt hat dann vom 247
Support gesagt ja warum hat uns da noch keiner
Bescheid gesagt, wenn heute Nacht die
Telefone weg sind, wenn dann bei uns gerade ein Ausfall ist,
was machen wir dann dann? Und sowas in der Richtung.
Das war ein Chain Advisory Board. Und
daraufhin kam dann immer
die Standardantwort, ja,
das nehme ich mit. Und da
habe ich mich auch immer gefragt, okay,
was passiert, also wie kann ich mir das
jetzt vorstellen? Er nimmt das
mit. Also was passiert denn jetzt damit,
wenn er es mitnimmt?
Weil man hat dann eigentlich danach nichts
mehr von gehört.
Das wurde immer nur, die Sachen wurden
immer nur mitgenommen.
Ja, hätte er jetzt gesagt,
okay, das spreche ich nochmal an,
dass die auch alle Bescheid wissen
und wir sagen euch dann nochmal Bescheid oder so.
Dann hätte ich das ja verstanden.
Aber das nehme ich mit.
Keine Ahnung, was das immer bedeuten sollte.
Das nehme ich mit.
Eigentlich gehst du mir gerade voll auf den Sack,
aber ich muss jetzt irgendwas sagen,
damit du Ruhe gibst.
Das ist die Übersetzung von das nehme ich mit.
Übrigens, wisst ihr, was mir auch nach Jahren im Change Advisory Board aufgefallen ist?
Wisst ihr, was mir da nach Jahren aufgefallen ist?
Vielleicht ist euch das auch schon aufgefallen.
Und zwar, je komplizierter und abstrakter du einen Change beschreibst, umso weniger Einwände oder Rückfragen gibt es.
Man würde eigentlich davon ausgehen, je vager und komplizierter was ist, umso mehr Rückfragen gibt es.
Aber es ist genau umgedreht. Wenn was einfach ist, dann kommen alle, weil sie was dazu sagen können, weil sie es verstehen.
Ja, also wenn du sagst, ja, also wir müssen dann demnächst auch mal die gesamte Stromversorgung im Rechenzentrum überdenken, ob das alles noch so zukunftsfähig ist.
und da kann es sein, dass demnächst einige Changes auf uns zukommen,
aber wir werden das dann rechtzeitig mit den Verantwortlichen besprechen.
Und weißt du, so was ganz Vages, wenn du so was ganz Vages sagst,
wo eigentlich alle sagen müssen, hä, Moment, was wollt ihr machen?
Die komplette Stromversorgung im Rechenzentrum, wait a minute,
Sekunde, mach mal langsam.
Und wenn du dann sagst, ja, und dann kommen wir dann auf euch zu
und wenn ihr noch Fragen habt, dann sagt einfach Bescheid,
keine Fragen, nix, null, niemand sagt
irgendwas zu, aber wenn du was ganz
banales sagst, wenn du was ganz
wirklich simples sagst, so nach dem Motto
ach übrigens, ähm, weiß nicht
ob ihr es mitbekommen habt, äh, morgen
wird auf der Homepage, äh, das neue
Logo eingebunden, da kommen sie
alle an, ihr habt ja auch drauf geachtet, dass
das pixelmäßig unten richtig ist
und da ist das auch die richtige Farbe und
haha, das ist ja nicht richtig transparent und
das CSS sieht auch nicht richtig, da ist
wirklich, je einfachster, umso
einfacher die Sache ist
1000 Leute sagen was zu
je abstrakter, komplizierter
und potenziell
umfassender und größer und gefährlicher
das sagt keiner was zu
das heißt, wenn ihr einfach
was durchgewunken haben wollt
sagt es nicht klar, sondern
sagt es möglichst kompliziert
ist jetzt natürlich eigentlich
kontraproduktiv
da sagt keiner was zu
ihr müsst das einfach möglichst
möglichst abstrakt und
ungreifbar machen, dann sagt keiner was zu.
Nur nicht
einfach und klar
erklären, dann
weil umso mehr, ist doch logisch,
umso mehr die Sachen verstehen, umso mehr
Leute wollen was zu sagen. Weil ja solche
Meetings auch immer ein bisschen
dazu einladen,
hast du was gesagt, klingst du halt wichtig.
Wir hatten
beispielsweise auch einen bei uns,
in der alten Firma, der hat prinzipiell immer das, was du gesagt hast,
nochmal so ein bisschen wiederholt und dann noch was angefügt.
Kennt ihr auch so Leute?
Ja, ihr sagt dann beispielsweise, ja, morgen Abend müssen wir auch Web-Server ABC rebooten.
Rebooten
und
dann sagt er dann
a
morgen wird also die Web-Applikation auf Server A und C oder auf A und B rebooted
wie sieht es denn aus
wie ist denn dann kommt er dann immer mit irgendeinem Zeug so
ja wie ist denn da die Wiederanlaufdokumentation oder wie so ein random Kram kommt da
sagst ja äh du tippst Reboot ein wartest fünf Minuten und dann ist alles wieder da und läuft das
Ah, und wird das auch nach einem Vier-Augen-Prinzip durchgeführt?
Oder irgend so ein random Shit, wo du dann denkst, Alter, das ist der 8000. Server, der auf die gleiche Art rebooted wird, was willst du jetzt eigentlich?
Du kennst das doch, das ist doch nichts Neues dazu.
Das ist doch alles genau das Gleiche wie immer.
Das ist alles das Gleiche wie immer.
Ja, und dann kam er noch immer an mit, sollten wir da vielleicht eine Rufbereitschaft dafür organisieren. Und dann habe ich mal zu ihm gesagt, sinngemäß, so nach dem Motto, du bist doch der Change Manager, weißt du was, ich überlasse das einfach dir, du kannst eine Rufbereitschaft organisieren, ich schicke dir einfach das Ticket, mach damit, was du willst.
Nein, nein, das muss schon der Change-Beauftrager machen.
Der Change, dass derjenige, der den Change eingestellt hat.
Ihr hättet natürlich im Vorfeld zu mir kommen können,
aber, ähm, also, da wollt ihr es dann auch nicht mehr machen.
Das war schon Spezialist in dem alten Laden, Alter.
Oh Mann.
Hast du schon die Dramadoku von
welcher Carsten?
Was ist denn nun mit Carsten los?
Äh?
Kennt ihr?
Ach, der Carsten.
Okay, nee, hab ich nicht geguckt. Juckt mich auch nicht.
Was ist denn da schon wieder für Drama?
was habe ich denn verpasst?
Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein,
das ist ein anderer.
Die Leute wollen nicht mitdenken.
Die wollen einfach nur auf diesen Meetings was sagen.
Da geht es überhaupt nicht drum.
Da geht es überhaupt nicht drum,
irgendwas Sinnvolles zu sagen.
Die wollten einfach nur irgendwie mal
sich ins Gespräch gebracht haben.
Darf ich Rufbereitschaft machen für den Reboot?
Also in der neuen Firma würde ich sofort Rufbereitschaft machen für den Reboot.
Da gibt es Fettkohle.
Also Leute, wir gucken...
Wir gucken kein FireShip.
Das ist mir einfach zu viel...
Zu viel AI.
AI, AI, AI, AI.
Läuft die Nase?
Ja, mich juckt es nicht, was 4chan treibt.
Was passiert, wenn die Sonne plötzlich schwarz wird?
Ja, dann würde ich sagen, wird es ganz schön dunkel.
nach acht minuten
busfahrer traumjob den keiner will ist der job so scheiße also wenn ich mir die
Leute anguckt, die da so generell im Bus rumgammeln.
Ja, wahrscheinlich ist da schon
Scheiße.
War das hier
vor... Ja, seit Jahren
schon.
Bei 4chan weißt du halt immer nicht, ist das jetzt wirklich
Next Level
League von irgendwas?
Oder dummes Gespämme?
Das weißt du meistens immer erst später.
Das ist halt das Problem an den Sachen, die da gepostet werden.
Da wurden ja schon viele wahre Sachen gepostet auf 4chan, das hat bloß keiner ernst genommen.
Weil sie sich gedacht haben, okay, 4chan weiß halt nicht.
Könnte natürlich auch sein, dass sie einfach per Zufall richtig gelegen haben und es gar nicht wussten.
So.
Lass uns mal schauen, wir können auch bestimmt hier irgendwie...
Was haben wir denn hier?
Das hatten wir schon.
AI, AI, AI.
Handys sind ein bisschen lame geworden.
Also, ich muss sagen, ich kenne mich YouTube Deutschland überhaupt nicht aus.
Ich habe noch nie ein Video gesehen von ihm.
Aber er hat 1,12 Millionen Subscriber.
Krass, oder?
Es gab mal eine Zeit lang, da kannte ich jeden auf YouTube, der über 100k hat.
Also, Deutschland.
Und, äh...
Auf einmal hast du Leute random am Start, ey.
Ne, wir gucken jetzt, was der Tiefbau und Bergretter verdient.
Wahrscheinlich viel zu wenig.
Weil es ist einfach so, ich habe euch das ja das letzte Mal schon erklärt.
In Berufen, oder wie sage ich das jetzt am besten?
Es ist ja immer so die Diskussion nach dem Motto, ey, warum verdient einer im Krankenhaus viel weniger als einer, der den ganzen Tag noch vorm Computer sitzt und irgendwelches Zeug für eine Versicherung oder für eine Bank macht.
Das ist ganz einfach.
Weil im Krankenhaus geht es nur um Menschenleben.
Und in der Bank geht es um Millionen Euro.
Also logisch, was da mehr Geld bringt unterm Schluss, oder?
Ob das jetzt richtig falsch, moralisch gut oder schlecht ist, will ich jetzt an der Stelle nicht bewerten.
Aber unterm Schluss ist es so.
Deswegen wird er wahrscheinlich auch weniger verdienen, als den, den wir uns das letzte Mal angeguckt haben.
Ich meine, seriously, guck mal.
Ich weiß auch nicht, warum mein Arsch so läuft.
Ich habe kein Heuschnupfen oder so.
Aber die Polen sind wieder ganz schön aggressiv am Fliegen die letzten Tage.
Aber daran kann es eigentlich nicht liegen.
Ich habe das Fenster zu und wie gesagt, ich habe keinen Heuschnupfen.
Also ich habe nichts in der Richtung.
Ja, aber das habe ich das letzte Mal schon erzählt. Also guckt mal, bei uns ist es so, wir bekommen richtig viel Kohle für Rufbereitschaft. Und da kann man sich jetzt natürlich fragen, ey, warum gibt es bei euch so viel Geld für Rufbereitschaft?
Ich beschwere mich da nicht drüber, ich nehme auch noch gerne noch mehr Geld für Rufbereitschaft, vollkommen okay.
Aber man muss sich das halt mal realistisch angucken, wie sowas zustande kommt.
Bei uns hat sich mal irgendjemand überlegt, okay, wir haben hier, was weiß ich, irgendwelche Services, die wir anbieten oder irgendwelche Plattformen,
worüber, was auch immer gehandelt wird oder irgendwelche Sachen abgeschlossen werden.
Und irgendjemand hat gesagt, ey, wenn die Plattform für eine Stunde ausfällt,
kostet uns das, ich sage jetzt einfach mal 5 Millionen Euro.
Das hat mal irgendjemand ausgerechnet.
Und dann haben die sich gedacht, okay, dann setzen wir doch lieber 24-7 da irgendwelche Leute hin,
die, wenn es denn wirklich mal kaputt geht, wir anrufen können, für den einen Fall der Fälle, wo das innerhalb von ein paar Jahren mal vorkommt, aber wir das nach einer Viertelstunde wieder am Laufen haben, als nach zwei Stunden, hat sich das schon komplett gelohnt.
Hat sich mal irgendeiner ausgerechnet.
Von nichts kommt das ja nicht.
Das haben die sich überlegt.
So, und im Gegensatz zu dem, bei anderen Jobs ist es halt so, ja gut, im Zweifelsfall kostet es ja nur was.
Also, die, wie soll man das sagen, die Abwägung hat in den meisten Jobs stattgefunden.
Man hat gesagt, okay, das ist es uns halt einfach nicht wert, hängt nicht genug Kohle dran.
Ob das jetzt gut oder schlecht ist, sei mal dahingestellt.
Deswegen vermute ich halt auch mal, dass der Tiefbau und Bergkletter weniger verdient, als den IT-Typ, den wir letzte Woche hatten.
So, gucken wir mal.
Zeitarbeit in der Pflege verdient man auch ziemlich gut.
Das ist richtig, das habe ich letztens auch was drüber gelesen.
Und zwar ist es wohl so, dass nicht nur in der Pflege, sondern auch was so medizinische Sachen angeht, wenn du da flexibel bist, das heißt, dass du quasi sagst, ey, ist mir egal, wo ihr mich in Deutschland einsetzt, ich kann morgen in Hamburg sein oder heute in Frankfurt, da kannst du richtig fett Kohle machen, weil die händeringend Leute suchen und halt gerade dort, wo gerade Lücken zu besetzen sind, wird wohl richtig gut bezahlt.
Also da kannst du dich wohl auch dumm und dämlich verdienen in dem Bereich.
Aber wohl nur, wenn du wirklich dieses
Ich-ist-mir-egal-wo-ich-eingesetzt-werde bist.
Man muss sich konzentrieren und bei der Arbeit
auch 100% bei dem dabei sein, was man macht.
Ja, sonst fällst du runter und du bist auch platt.
Wenn wir kommen, machen wir das, was eigentlich Sicherheit gibt, weg.
Oh nein, Trostmusik.
Warum ist es null?
YouTube, was ist da los?
Ich bin absolut zufrieden mit meinem Gehalt.
Keck wie JavaScript kann man nur dazu sagen.
Mein Name ist Franz Dörfler, ich bin 28 Jahre alt, arbeite im alpinen Tiefbau als Vorarbeiter
und wir befinden uns jetzt hier gerade in meiner Heimatgemeinde Greinau und hinter mir
sieht man den Arbeitsort der Höhentalklammer.
Alpiner Tiefbau ist im Grunde genommen...
Reinau, das ist irgendwo an der Zugspitze, oder?
Irgendwo in Bayern, Alpenzugspitze?
Das sagt mir was.
Das heißt, wir machen Wegebau...
Muss ich mal kurz gucken, das kenne ich.
Reinau.
Zugspitze.
Bavaria, südlich Bayern, Garmisch-Baden-Kirch, ja genau.
Leitungsbau, aber auch Sachen wie Klettersteigbau oder Kleinkläranlagen für Hütten,
genauso wie Versorgungsleitungen für Seilbahnen.
Also alles, was irgendwo mit Bergen und schwierigen Geländen zu tun hat, das ist eigentlich so unser Aufgabengebiet.
Wir sind hier rum, gerade an der Höllentaleingangshütte.
Wir gehen gleich in die Höllentalklamm.
Seit gestern ist die gesperrt.
Wir haben gestern angefangen, dass wir Brücken und Geländer abbauen.
Einmal müssen wir Rohr abbauen und eine Brücke müssen wir noch abbauen.
Dann ist die Klamm eigentlich winterfest und alles soweit sicher.
Man muss sowas winterfest machen?
Keine Lawinen und irgendwelche Schäden anrichten können.
Wir haben kein Geländer mehr zum Festhalten.
Wir müssen gut aufpassen und es ist immer rutschig in der Klamm.
Ist das Herr der Ringe Musik? Hört sich ein bisschen so an, oder?
Das ist 100 pro Herr der Ringe!
100 pro!
Hier ist eigentlich Klammende.
Da vorne gleich ums Eck steht dann auch das Schild Klammende.
Also hier hört eigentlich die Hauptarbeit auf.
Wisst ihr auch, wo davon eine Drosselung vornimmt, wenn man große Datenmengen lädt? Keine Ahnung.
Aber wenn das mobile ist, dann ist das doch bei fast allen irgendwie mit Beschränkung.
Das Unlimited ist doch immer nur Unlimited bis zu. Das ist eh die größte Beschiss überhaupt.
Unlimited heißt ja nur, dass sie dich nicht abschalten, nicht dass du nicht gedrosselt wirst.
Also mein Bauchgefühl sagt mir ab einer gewissen Menge mobilen Daten, werden sie dich trotzdem drosseln.
Achso, ja DSL wahrscheinlich nicht. Ne, also da habe ich jetzt nichts von gehört, dass da irgendwas getrosselt wird.
Der Beginn für heute. Die Seile sind schon weg und wir machen jetzt alle immer zwei Schrauben auf, Stützen weg und die werden dann im Tunnel deponiert, dass die vor Witterung geschützt sind.
Mein Papa hat die Firma vor über 30 Jahren gegründet, habe dementsprechend auch schon
als Kind immer mitgearbeitet und für mich war immer klar, irgendwann werde ich zu Hause
mit einsteigen. Habe aber meine Lehre nach dem Abitur in München gemacht zum technischen
Produktdesigner nach vier Jahren München. Mittlerweile habe ich echt Probleme anhand
der Jobbezeichnung zu erkennen, was der denn eigentlich macht. Was macht ein technischer
Produktdesigner? Ich hätte absolut keinen blassen Schimmer. Ich wollte dann doch wieder nach Hause,
in die Berge und so kam es dann, dass ich zu Hause im Familienbetrieb eingestiegen bin.
Bei so Stellen wie hier. Bei mir gibt es eine Rückkopplung. Wirklich?
Wie kommst du da drauf? Rauscht das irgendwie? Moment, das muss ich mir anhören. Wartet mal.
Ach so, bei denen. Warte mal hier, Test Test. Ja, eigentlich ist alles okay.
Lass ich immer eine Schraube dran, bis er in irgendeine Richtung kommt.
Sind das Einhell-Akkuschrauber? Das sind die einzigen, die mir einfallen, die rot sind.
Wenn ich ihn noch erwische, lege ich ihn auf den Weg, mache dann erst die zweite Schraube auf. Dann liegt er immer sicher.
Milwaukee sind auch rot, ja.
Wetter ist immer ein ganz großes Thema. Wir können nicht bei jedem Wetter jede Arbeit
machen. Wie in der Klamm zum Beispiel, da ist es immer nass. Also wenn es jetzt noch
zusätzlich regnet, ist es halt noch mehr nass, aber grundsätzlich können wir da auch,
wenn es regnet hin. Ist klar, die Stimmung ist nicht immer hoch, brauchen wir nicht drüber
reden. Aber es ist vor allem auch in der Klamm immer was Besonderes. Auch wenn du nass bist
auf die Unterkunft. Bayrisch-Beste.
Oh, sie bist. Da genießt du einfach.
Wisst ihr, was der, also ohne Mist,
ich kann es an der Stelle immer sagen,
es gibt ja Leute, die sagen, Sächsisch
ist der schlimmste Dialekt und sowas.
Finde ich nicht. Für mich ist so Berliner,
dieser Berliner Dialekt ist für mich
das schlimmste, schlimmste deutsche
Dialekt, den es gibt.
Bayrisch ist nice,
ja. Hessisch mag ich auch,
gegen Sächsisch habe ich gar nichts.
Aber Berliner,
dieses Berliner-Deutsch, das ist so
Das tut weh!
Ja, das ist Herr der Regenmusiker.
Gestern hat es geregnet.
Wie man hinter mir in den Wasserfällen und auch seitlich an der Wand sieht,
ist das Wasser deutlich mehr, als wenn es lange trocken war.
Jeder möchte schnell nach Hause, weil es doch recht nass wird.
Gleichzeitig muss man viel mehr aufpassen.
Es ist alles noch rutschiger und man ist doch kalt und nass.
Die Aufmerksamkeit muss viel mehr bei der Arbeit sein,
weil niemand will da unten im Wasser liegen.
Aber die Musik passt auch gut dazu.
Wir haben jetzt kurz vor 12, sind jetzt eigentlich mit den Geländern soweit durch.
Wir machen jetzt ein bisschen Mittagspause.
Wisst ihr, was mir da auffällt im Vergleich zu vielen anderen dieser Videos?
Der macht ja wirklich was am Tag.
Der weiß am Ende des Tages halt auch, was er gemacht hat.
Zu lang, weil wir doch alle ein bisschen nass sind.
Schön ist es auch, wenn man irgendwo am Berg sitzt
und da schön Brotzeit machen kann.
Dass wir in der Hütte sitzen, eher selten.
Erst mal Gummistiefel anziehen und noch mal wetterfest machen.
Dann geh ich mit dem Pferd nach hinten
und bauen jetzt das Rohr ab.
In der Mitte der Klamm haben wir eine lange Treppe und da sehen Besucher, wenn sie reingehen,
nur einen Wasserfall.
Der Wasserfall ist aber nicht natürlich, sondern da ist oben drüber ein Rohr, das
das Wasser sammelt und über den Weg drüber leitet.
Und das müssen wir ja selbstverständlich auch im Winter abbauen und im Frühjahr wieder
aufbauen.
Freust du dich?
Ist das Rügenwalder? Wie kommst du auf Rügenwalder jetzt bitteschön?
Rügenwalder, das ist die mit der Mühle, oder wie war das?
Feierabend, wie das duftet. Kräftig, deftig, herzhaft, gut.
Oder so in der Richtung.
Aber grundsätzlich ist alles, was mit steilem Gelände, mit Seilsicherung, mit nicht alltäglichen
Aufgaben, das ist das, was mir am meisten taugt an der ganzen Arbeit.
muss sich konzentrieren und bei der Arbeit auch 100% bei dem dabei sein, was man macht.
Ja, das sieht äußerst anstrengend aus, muss ich sagen.
Dann machen wir erst das obere locker, den da. Dass der da schon mal locker ist.
Wait a minute, warum will er genau das locker machen, wo er dranhängt?
Und dann mache ich den auf,
und von den rauskriege und wir rausgehen.
Ich glaube nicht, dass das so gemeint war.
Was hat sich so angehört?
Bist du mal in der Zeit,
wo die gefühlt jetzt irgendwie da
alle Geländer abgebaut haben
und ein Rohr gewechselt haben und sonst was,
habe ich Daily Scrum und Daily Team Dings gemacht.
Also der hat eindeutig mehr gearbeitet in der Zeit.
Sehr nass, aber schneller gegangen als ich dachte.
Da haben wir Sprint Review gemacht in der Zeit.
Alles super.
Im August 24 waren es bei mir knapp 4.950 Euro brutto. Das sind nach allen Abzügen ca. 3.070 Euro netto, die mir noch übrig bleiben.
Ich sag doch, der schafft richtig was und verdient nur die Hälfte von den anderen.
Das war aber auch ein sehr guter Monat, weil wir da recht viel...
Das halt... Für das, wie anstrengend das ist...
Arbeitszeit und Stunden gehabt haben. Also das hat mit der Familienangehörigkeit überhaupt nichts zu tun.
Das hat eher mit meinen Qualifikationen zu tun.
Allein der Fuhrunternehmer, für den ich die Prüfung gemacht habe, ist ein eigener Beruf.
Auch meine Qualifikation als Lkw-Fahrer, Maschinenführer, all das spielt da natürlich mit rein.
Wir sind heute sehr gut vorangekommen, sind sehr schnell fertig geworden.
Ja, und der Vater ist auch noch der Chef.
Das macht keinen Sinn, jetzt noch irgendwo weiterzuarbeiten.
IT ist so aus dem Ruder gelaufen.
Nee, ich sehe das umgedreht.
IT sollte eigentlich der Standard sein.
Alle anderen sollten einfach mehr kriegen.
Sonst sind morgen alle krank.
Ich gehe jetzt dann nach Hause, werde mich umziehen
und dann habe ich zu Hause noch eine eigene Baustelle.
Dann geht es beim Umbau weiter.
Der Hedderinge-Soundtrack ist schon echt geil.
Ich wohne in meinem Elternhaus.
im Erdgeschoss meine Eltern, ich mit meiner Freundin und mit meinem Kind im ersten Stock
und der zweite Stock befindet sich jetzt gerade noch im Umbau. Das da drüben war früher mein
Kinderzimmer. Das war das Kinderzimmer meiner Schwester und hier war das Schlafzimmer von
meinem Bruder. Haben wir jetzt so ziemlich außer das Schlafzimmer von meinem Bruder alles umgebaut.
Also hier ist die Küche, Wohnzimmer und hier geht es dann schon wieder hoch zur Baustelle.
Den Holzbau außen, die Wände, hat mir Zimmerei gemacht, aber auch den Innenausbau, jetzt das
Strom und Dämmen, das mache ich alles alleine, auch wieder mit Freunden zusammen. Das Haus ist
mittlerweile mein Eigentum, das wurde mir von meinen Eltern überschrieben, das hier wird Zukunft.
Ja, muss ich mal vorstellen, das stimmt schon, Chad. Der ist heftig am Arbeiten,
auf der eigentlichen Arbeit, dann macht er daheim noch weiter. So, und ich habe Sprint,
Review und Daily Scrum gemacht und danach bin ich müde. Ich habe keinen Bock, meinen restlichen Tag
was zu machen. Ich aufstieg in mein Schlafzimmer mit wunderschönem Bergblick. Das Projekt hat mir jetzt
doch ein halbes Jahr gekostet, bis ich jetzt mal auf diesen Stand bin. Aktuell kann ich es ungefähr
auf zwischen 75.000 und 80.000 Euro. Ich bin jetzt aktuell bei den Baumaßnahmen, die ja bis jetzt
jetzt stemmen haben müssen. Also ich bin ehrenamtlich bei der Bergwacht in Greinau tätig. Wir haben im Jahr
vier bis fünf Dienstwochen, je nachdem wie der Dienstplan fällt. Das heißt fünf Wochen im Sommer
von Freitag bis Freitag, 24 Stunden, sieben Tage die Woche auf Alleinbereitschaft. Das ist einfach
Das ist auch noch ehrenfreiwillig, unbezahlt. Eine Leidenschaft und das war sie in der Freizeit.
Ich hab jetzt nicht hingeguckt, hab mal nachgesehen, ob es was dafür noch gab.
...gern mach, noch anderen zur Verfügung zu stellen.
Von Juni bis August wurden wir von einer Produktion vom ARD begleitet bei unserer Arbeit als Bergwacht,
die einfach mal nach außen zeigt, was eigentlich unsere Arbeit ist.
...der Notruf für Feuerwehr und Rettungsdienst, mit wem spreche ich bitte?
Englisch.
Englisch?
Okay, der Menschenkoll.
Where are you?
What happened?
I'm on top of the mountain.
On the top of Zugspitze?
Yes.
On top of Zugspitze?
I'm afraid there's lightning everywhere.
Gewitter in den Bergen ist das Schlechteste,
das du haben kannst.
Gewitter in den Bergen bedeutet immer Lebensgefahr
in unbeschreiblichem Maße.
Allein, dass ich zu Hause bin, bei meiner Familie bin und den Job mache, den ich gern
mache, dafür lohnt sich das.
Bei einem Wetter wie heute, draußen zu sein, in der Natur zu sein und im besten Fall auch noch in den Bergen zu sein,
das macht alles wett.
Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss.
Mir kommt es irgendwie so vor, wenn ich diese Sachen angucke,
das potenziell, jetzt einfach nur gesagt,
die Leute, die so einen Job machen
wie der, vielleicht
vom
Gehalt nicht so viel verdienen wie die anderen,
aber dass die in der Regel
glücklicher mit ihrem Job sind.
Also
beispielsweise die eine
was
war das
Unternehmensberaterin
oder so, die wir da mal geguckt
haben, die den ganzen Tag nur Excel gemacht hat,
Die hat nicht den Eindruck gemacht, als ist sie sonderlich glücklich mit ihrem Job.
Und der hingegen hat den Eindruck gemacht, als ist er richtig happy.
So, Leute, so wir gerade dabei sind, wir müssen jetzt noch mal eine Runde hier.
Bester Soundtrack, oder?
Also ohne Scheiß.
Das ist nicht Thor's Herr der Ringe Musik, kannst du auf Twitch spielen, es joggt kein.
Herr der Ringe Soundtrack ist echt beste.
Aber Chat, ihr habt recht, man könnte mal wieder in der Regel gucken.
Bis morgen reicht es gerade so, gell?
So, was haben wir denn sonst noch hier?
Warum niemand ins Handwerk will?
Ob nicht, dass wir das gucken wollen?
Die Altware?
Keine Ahnung, ich weiß nicht, ob man das gesehen hat.
25 oder so? 26?
Rate ich jetzt einfach mal.
Keine Ahnung.
28?
Okay.
Das ist ja bescheuere Empfehlung heute.
Ey, das ist jetzt schon so.
Jetzt schon ist...
das keinerlei problem da irgendwelche aufträge zu bekommen oder oder so wenn
du was richtung handwerk was es ist jetzt schon teilweise unmöglich wenn
wir angenommen angenommen nur theoretischer fall ich sag jetzt ich
möchte mir doch eine solaranlage aufs dach packen
was meint ihr wie lange es dauern würde bzw wie teuer ist wäre werden würde bis
das hier man macht bei mir also das ist nix das ist nix was jetzt irgendwie wo
man sagen könnte ach ja kommen drei wochen geht's los oder so und es wird
auch teuer es deswegen umso besser chat dass wir ja als alte bastl hacker
Man's vieles selbst machen können
ich meine
Gerüst aufbauen und
Solaranlage aufs dach bauen jetzt weniger aber ansonsten können wir relativ viel selbst machen
Das stimmt schon ja manche also ich glaube gerade hier im stream ist der anteil der leute die
Ein bisschen selbst was basteln können doch relativ hoch
Was mich immer wieder verwirrt ist, wie viel Schiss normale Leute davor haben, Technik-Sachen überhaupt anzufassen.
Ja?
Letztens kam meine Mutter zu mir und meinte, ey, die Waschmaschine, da läuft Wasser raus.
Äh, okay, ich habe keine Ahnung von Waschmaschinen, aber du bist ein Weib-Elektriker.
Ich stell mir grad vor, wie das läuft.
Hast dann quasi ein Handy dabei.
Und machst ein Foto.
Und fragst ChatGPT.
Ich muss jetzt dort hier irgendwie noch eine neue Sicherung dran machen.
Wie geht das?
Wobei, ne, Vibe-Elektrik würde ja eigentlich heißen, du hast ein AI, die das für dich macht.
Naja, zumindest
meine Mutter hat letztens gesagt,
hier guck mal, da kommt Wasser aus der
aus der Waschmaschine.
Und ich hab gesagt, hä, wie? Ich hab keine Ahnung
von Waschmaschinen, aber ich guck mal.
So. Und am Ende
war das was ganz Simples.
Und zwar, ich kann euch das mal zeigen,
an
Waschmaschinen, ja, da gibt es so
Ich habe vergessen, wie das heißt.
Wasser, so ein Wasserstopp.
Heißt es nicht sogar Wasserstopp?
Aquastopp.
Aquastoppschlauch.
Ja, sowas gibt es da.
So ein Ding, so in der Richtung sieht das aus.
Für alle, die nicht wissen, was das ist, versuche ich das mal kurz zu erklären.
weil ich wusste es bis zu dem zeitpunkt auch nicht nicht dass ich jetzt irgendwie
ist besonders schlau wieder rüberkommen will oder so ich hatte bis zu dem
zeitpunkt auch keine ahnung und das ist so das ist ein schlauch in
einem schlauch und wenn der innere schlauch kaputt geht weil es ein leck
gibt dann füllt sich der äußere schlauch und hier ist ein sensor drin wenn wasser
über den äußeren schlauch quasi hoch läuft dann erkennt dass der sensor und
blockiert den Zufluss. Das ist so das Prinzip von so einem Aquastopp. Das ist eigentlich eine ganz simple Geschichte.
Das ist ein Schlauch in Schlauch und mit einem Sensor im Endeffekt. Wenn der äußere Schlauch Wasser enthält,
dann stoppt das die Wasserzufuhr. Das sorgt im Endeffekt dazu, dass wenn du unterwegs bist und die Waschmaschine
irgendwie ein Leck an
der Wasser- und Wasserzufluss hat,
dass dann nicht
das Bad unter Wasser steht.
Und wenn der äußere Schlauch kaputt geht,
dann müsste ja der innere und der äußere Schlauch
zeitgleich kaputt gehen, dann hast du wahrscheinlich gelitten.
Wobei es immer noch die Frage ist,
ob der äußere Schlauch ein großes Leck hat,
wenn es ein kleines Leck ist, füllt er sich trotzdem.
Wichtig ist halt nur, dass der
Sensor auslöst. So, und so ein Ding
war da dran
und ich hab mir das angeguckt und hab mir gedacht,
ey,
da ist, es ist hier oben
ist das, ist das rausgequollen
quasi dann, hier oben ist es
am Wasserhahn ist das rausgequollen, ey weißt du was
das ist einfach
nicht richtig dran
ich hab das Ding von der Hand
drehen können und alles, hab gesagt, ey weißt du
das ist einfach nicht richtig dran, da ist nichts kaputt
vielleicht ist auch die
vielleicht ist die
Dichtung kaputt, das ist jetzt ja auch schon über
fast 15 Jahre so
und vielleicht
Aber ich glaube, das ist einfach nicht richtig dran.
So, dann bin ich hoch und hab meine...
Michael5Tb, danke schön für den Sub.
Und hab meine Allzweckwaffe für solche Schraubedinger geholt.
Nämlich, ich hab eine Knippex Cobra.
Cobra.
Was auch die ganzen Klempner und so haben.
So eine Cobra-Zange.
Und wollte das festschrauben.
Ich hab gesagt, weißt du was?
wir schrauben das jetzt mal ab
und
dann gucken wir mal wie die Dichtung aussieht
und dann schrauben wir das wieder dran
so und dann habe ich es mal testweise
so einmal ein bisschen hinter gedreht hier
quasi das Ding
also Problem bei uns unten im Bad
ist, dass ihr seht hier
das hier kann man nicht so ohne weiteres drehen
wenn es zu nah an der Wand ist, weil es hier so ein Wulst hat
das heißt ich konnte es nur ein bisschen hinter drehen
da habe ich es ein bisschen hinter gedreht
und habe gesagt, hier, jetzt gucken wir mal, ob das schon reicht.
Einfach nur, ob es das ist.
Ich habe es quasi nur provisorisch
gefixt, indem ich das so eine Viertelumdrehung
noch nach hinten gedreht habe mit der Hand,
bis es halt
wegen dem Wulst nicht weiter ging. So, und jetzt
kommt das Eigentliche, was ich erzählen will.
Danach hat sie die Waschmaschine angemacht
und es ging nicht mehr. Aber sie hat gesagt, okay, dann
liegt das daran, dann schrauben
wir das jetzt ab, gucken wir mal, wie es mit
der Dichtung aussieht
und dann schrauben wir das ordentlich wieder dran.
Da meinte sie so, nein, nein, jetzt, wo es
gerade geht. Lass bloß die Finger von weg.
Jetzt geht's doch gerade. Nicht wieder
abmachen. Dann geht's ja vielleicht wieder kaputt.
Ich hab gesagt, hä?
Wie jetzt? Willst du, dass
das in einem halben Jahr
wieder kaputt geht oder so?
Das macht nix. Hauptsache, jetzt geht's.
Bloß nicht die Finger dran.
Hab ich mir gedacht, alter Leute,
meine Güte, ey, ist ja alles solche
Schisser immer, wenn's um so
Bastelkram geht. Kennt ihr das so, Leute?
Das triggert mich immer
übelst. Wenn du eigentlich genau
weißt, woran es liegt und du könntest es jetzt
ordentlich fixen und die Leute
dann Panik schieben, genauso wie
mein Opa immer mit dem Fernseher
früher. Für meinen Opa war
der Fernseher so ein
Altar, würde ich sagen.
Also so ein Ding,
das hat man den ganzen Tag benutzt als
Entertainmentquelle, aber es war quasi
von höherer Macht
betrieben. Also eine
höhere Macht hat quasi den Fernseher
zum Funktionieren gebracht für meinen Opa.
Der hat absolut nicht
gecheckt, dass das halt ein Fernseher ist und
wie ein Fernseher funktioniert.
Ich will nicht sagen, dass ich groß an der Elektronik
im Tränen was hätte machen können, aber so die Basics,
ja, und der hat jedes Mal,
wenn beispielsweise
irgendwelche Sender oder so,
die die Frequenz
geändert haben, das war ja damals noch analoges
Fernsehsignal,
wenn Sender die Frequenz geändert haben,
da hat der Typ allen Ernstes
bei so einem Audio-Video-Geschäft angerufen,
hat jemand bestellt,
der dann für ihn Sendesuchlauf gemacht hat.
Und da habe ich damals schon, wie ich klein war, keine Ahnung wie alt ich da war, irgendwie 10 oder so,
habe ich zu meinem Opa gesagt, Opa, hier, Fernbedienung, Sendesuchlauf.
Und er hatte da Angst davor, einen Sendesuchlauf zu machen.
Der wollte das nicht, der hat gedacht, der Fernseher implodiert, wenn er jetzt Sendesuchlauf macht.
und er hat halt auch wie gesagt für den war der fernseher ein gerät was quasi von irgendeiner
höheren macht betrieben wurde wo man keine eine ahnung kein einfluss und der einzige
der das machen konnte ist quasi der techniker vom audio video laden das sind so sachen dass
das dass das regt mich immer auf weil die meisten technik dinger die sind vielleicht
nicht unbedingt so gebaut dass man viele technik dinge sind nicht gerade so gebaut dass man sie
easy versteht wo man sich so wo man sich denkt die hersteller machen es absichtlich absichtlich
kompliziert aber gerade wir die in dieser generation aufgewachsen sind wo man eben noch
viel selbst machen konnte an technik sachen wir haben so ein gewisses grundlegendes gespür dafür
wie technikgeräte funktionieren ich kann es nicht anders beschreiben aber vielleicht kennt ihr das
Das ist was, was die Boomer-Generation und die Zoomer-Generation nicht hat.
Für die Zoomer-Generation ist das ganz normal, quasi auch wieder von Gott gegeben, dass das Handy das macht, was es macht.
Und sobald es das nicht mehr macht, hast du keine Ahnung mehr davon.
Und die ältere Generation, die ist schon wieder zu alt dafür.
Aber unsere Generation, wir haben so ein gewisses technisches Gespür dafür, wie Elektronikgeräte oder Technik-Sachen funktionieren.
Funktionieren man kann es oftmals gar nicht so genau erklären warum man es weiß wie es geht aber oftmals stehst du davor
Guckst du das gerät an drückst zweimal drauf weiß wie es funktioniert hat die sache nach fünf minuten gefixt
Ja und
Aber unsere generation ist das aber anders
Du bist das gleiche, mit 40 bist du die gleiche Generation wie ich.
Es fehlt das technische Verständnis, die haben da Angst davor, genau.
Das ist ein bisschen so wie, ähm, meine Mutter traut sich beispielsweise auch nicht am Fernsehen, ich mein, wir haben einen, ähm, von Sony einen Fernseher mit einem Shield-TV dran, also es ist ein Android-TV.
Und die guckt immer im Fernsehen so ZDF Herzkino und so Zeug.
So Samunde Pilcher und was gibt es denn da noch so? Inga Lindström.
und so Zeug guckt die.
Die guckt aber nicht nur das,
sondern die guckt beispielsweise auch Sachen bei Amazon
oder Sachen über die ZDF-App oder solche Geschichten.
Und jedes Mal, wenn die umgeschalten muss,
von Amazon Prime Video zu Fernsehgucken
gucken über kabelanschluss ruft die mich
wie kriegt das nicht hin also die logik von du musst einfach auf das muss auf
der start menü und dann machst du entweder kodi auf wenn der fernseh gucken
willst du machst beim video auf eine beim video auf gucken willst das ist für
uns so eine so eine so eine basic sache das ist bei uns komplett in fleisch und
blut übergegangen dass uns so eine bedienung von solchen geräten einfach für uns ist das
komplett klar und logisch und wenn ich jetzt sagen würde ich will netflix gucken gehe ich
ins hauptmenü macht die netflix app auf aber die versteht das nicht die versteht das nicht
die hat kodi auf und guckt keine ahnung rosamunde pilcher dann will sie amazon aufmachen und da
irgendwas gucken und dann ruft die dann sagt die da sagt die die hat mich sogar schon angerufen
deswegen und mittlerweile habe ich so gemacht wir haben eine wir haben eine neue schild tv
remote hier die dreieckige habe ich jetzt letztens gekauft so und jetzt passt jetzt
Jetzt passt mal auf. Bestes Beispiel dafür.
Bestes Beispiel dafür. Also.
Das ist die neue Fernbedienung.
Wisst ihr, was der Homebutton auf dieser Fernbedienung ist?
Früher war bei Android TV so ein Häuschen auf dem Homebutton.
Was könnte der Homebutton sein auf dieser Fernbedienung?
Ich gebe zu, ist nicht wirklich intuitiv.
Die drei Striche? Ne, ne, ne.
Der Punkt, richtig, der Punkt ist es.
Der Kreis ist es, ja genau.
Der Kreis ist es.
Der hier, das ist der Homebutton.
Er ist jetzt ziemlich dämlich gemacht.
Aber ich habe das einmal ausprobiert und wusste jetzt sofort,
die kann sich das bis heute nicht merken,
dass das der Homebutton ist, weil es kein Häuschen mehr hat.
Die kann es sich nicht merken.
Ich habe das einmalig ausprobieren müssen.
Ich dachte mir ehrlich gesagt schon, dass es der Button ist,
Weil zurück wird es nicht sein, vorwärts, Mikrofon, Dings wird es auch nicht sein.
Also muss es eigentlich der oder der sein.
Aber der hier ist es.
Das ist der Homebutton.
Ich habe das einmal in 10 Sekunden ausprobiert, rausgekriegt und seitdem weiß ich es.
Die kann sich das nicht merken.
Die kann sich das nicht merken, dass das der Startmenü-Button ist.
Die kriegt das nicht hin.
das ist kacke design ja aber ganz ehrlich das ist ein button den man sich merken muss ja die
kriegt das direkt kann sich das nicht merken ich verstehe das nicht also wir unsere generation wir
haben das so ein intuitives verständnis für uns wir merken uns das so und jetzt kommt noch noch
noch ein besseres beispiel so im prinzip benutzt die zwei apps darauf die benutzt prime video und
die benutzt Kodi für
normales Fernsehgucken und
Sachen aufnehmen. Und ich hab hier das
jetzt so gemappt.
Ich hab hier Android TV
Button Remapper.
Da gibt's eine Software.
Hier, Button Mapper.
Sowas in der Richtung hier.
Da kann man die Knöpfe umbelegen.
Was ich jetzt
gemacht hab, ist, weil ich sich das nicht merken kann,
in nur zwei Apps verwendet, ist,
ich hab gesagt, okay,
einmal kurz den Netflix-Button drücken
ist
Kodi starten für
Kabelfernseh gucken, ja
und einmal Netflix-Button
lang drücken ist
Prime Video starten.
Kriegt die nicht hin?
Die kriegt es nicht hin?
Und einmal
hat sie mich ganz geschockt.
Da habe ich sie gefragt, ey, weißt du noch
welcher Button,
welchen Button musst du drücken für Amazon?
Und dann meinte sie, ja, den mit dem Häuschen und dann gehe ich auf Prime Video.
Sie sagt, nein, es gibt keinen Button mehr mit dem Häuschen.
Häuschen-Button ist nicht mehr.
Guck mal, siehst du irgendwo einen Häuschen-Button auf dieser Fernbedienung?
Aber immerhin, gut, du hast ja das gemerkt, wie es vor fünf Jahren gewesen ist.
Also nein, du musst, du musst, es gibt, da habe ich gesagt, es gibt einen anderen Button.
Den kannst du drücken und dann geht es direkt auf.
Und die kam nicht drauf dass es der netflix button ist und sagt hast guck mal unten hast du doch so ein button als
Netflix aber sie will ja kein netflix gucken
Sie will doch kein netflix gucken sie will noch amazon gucken warum sollte sie den netflix button drücken
Es gibt leute die haben einfach kein verständnis dafür das geht nicht kannst nicht machen
Meine mutter ist 75 die ist gar nicht so schlecht was technik sachen angeht die lernt das auch mit der zeit
Die ist gar nicht so schlecht, was Technik-Kram angeht.
Beispielsweise, die verwendet mittlerweile nur noch Tablets.
Also die liest nur noch auf dem Tablet.
Also die hängen ganz nach am Tablet beispielsweise und sowas.
Die ist gar nicht schlecht, was so Technik-Sachen angeht.
Die hat natürlich auch ein bisschen was von mir gelernt die letzten Jahrzehnte über.
Aber das sind so Basic-Sachen, wisst ihr?
Egal, wer von euch im Chat ist jetzt.
Ich sage euch das einmal und ihr wisst es für immer, welcher Button das startet.
Ihr habt das einfach intuitiv drauf.
Ja, okay.
Aber um mal zurückzukommen zu der Aquastop-Geschichte.
Ich hab das dann temporär festgedreht
und hab gesagt, ey,
das ist nur zum Ausprobieren.
Die hat's ausprobiert und hat gemeint,
ich soll das bloß nicht wieder anfassen,
weil dann könnte es ja wieder kaputt gehen.
Und da musste ich die wirklich ernsthaft dazu überreden,
dass ich das Ding jetzt wieder losdrehe,
mal nach der, nach der, ähm,
äh, nicht nach der, ich wollte gerade sagen,
nach der Sicherung gucke,
nach der Dichtung gucke
und wieder zumache.
So, und ich habe das dann aber einfach so
gemacht. Ich habe gesagt, weißt du was, ich mache das jetzt ab. Ich habe keinen
Bock, dass es in zwei Wochen wieder anfängt,
hier Wasser rauszusprühen.
Da habe ich bei Amazon, wusste ich auch nicht, dass es
das gibt. Guck mal, es gibt bei Amazon
ein Dichtungs-
Sortiment.
Da kriegt man sowas hier.
Und da habe ich mir eins bestellt.
Sowas hier in der Richtung.
Sanitär ist Dichtungssortiment.
Hab ich mir bestellt.
Und man braucht dafür das da.
By the way.
Das da.
Braucht man dafür.
Da habe ich so eine Dichtung hier von rein gemacht.
Und hab das dann ordentlich festgedreht.
Auch so, dass es in die richtige Richtung zeigt.
Dass man sieht, ob der Aquastopp ausgelöst hat.
Und sowas.
Und ich hatte wirklich.
Das hat, das hat keine Ahnung.
eine Viertelstunde gedauert, bis ich das abgemacht hab,
getauscht hab und wieder dran geschraubt hab.
Die hat daneben gestanden, hat Schiss gehabt.
Die hat gedacht, ich zerstöre jetzt die Waschmaschine,
die geht nie wieder und bald muss eine neue
Waschmaschine her, weil ich den Schlauch
abgeschraubt hab oder sowas.
Ja, die hat wirklich Panik geschoben dabei.
Dass die Waschmaschine
gleich durchbrennt oder so.
Keine Ahnung.
Ja, das ist wirklich so.
Also, die Boomer-Generation hat keinen Plan von Technik und die Zoomer-Generation hat keinen Plan von Technik.
Aber bei unserer Generation funktioniert das irgendwie.
Die traut mir schon, dass ich das Zeug hinkriege.
Weil ich fix ja das meiste.
Wenn im Haus was kaputt ist.
Gerade was so Bastelkram ist, den man daheim fixen kann.
Aber dann überkommt die immer die Panik.
Oh, das könnte jetzt ja doch ganz schlimm werden und kaputt gehen.
Ja, sagen wir mal, vielleicht nicht Zuma. Ich meine halt, die Generation über, sagen wir mal, 45 plus, 50, 45, 50 plus und die Generation jetzt, sagen wir mal, unter 20.
die haben beide keine große ahnung von technik es gibt natürlich ausnahmen selbstverständlich
gibt es auch in der jüngeren generation welche die ahnung haben und auch in der älteren generation
die ahnung haben aber im durchschnitt würde ich sagen dass das verbreitetste technikverständnis
in der Generation jetzt, sagen wir mal, über 20, unter 50 herrscht.
Das sind gerade die Leute, die intuitiv halt solche Technik-Sachen richtig handeln.
So, setzt ja jemand vor ein neues Gerät, was er noch nie gesehen hat,
die haben keine Angst, da einfach mal ein bisschen drauf rumzudrücken
und zu gucken, was Sache ist und dann haben die es nach zwei Minuten verstanden
und können es einstellen und es geht.
Dafür wissen sie wie man TikToks aufnimmt
Ich nicht, das stimmt
Aber ich wette mit euch
Wir sind technisch so weit drinnen
Dass wir ohne Probleme, wenn wir wirklich wollten
Innerhalb von 5 Minuten wüssten wie man ein TikTok Video aufnimmt
Das ist ja der Unterschied
Die Generation die kriegt sowas relativ schnell raus
Das mag vielleicht daran liegen
Dass wir keinen Bock haben TikTok Videos aufzunehmen
Ja, es hat sich die letzten...
Na, ihr müsst euch nur mal...
Guckt euch einfach die letzten 100 Jahre an.
Überlegt euch mal.
1925.
Das war komplett andere Welt.
Das war so irgendwann nach dem Zweiten Weltkrieg.
Nach dem Ersten Weltkrieg oder so.
Erster Weltkrieg war 1918 oder sowas in dem Dreh.
Das war vor 100 Jahren, das war komplett, also wirklich eine komplett andere Welt als heute.
Schau dir die erste Staffel von Star Trek an.
Da habe ich letztens irgendwo mal einen coolen Vergleich gesehen,
wo wir schon weiter sind, als Star Trek gedacht hat
und wo wir hoffnungslos hinten dran sind.
Also gerade wo wir deutlich weiter sind als Star Trek ist,
guckt euch mal an, was sie da als Kommunikator verwenden.
So ein klobisches, fettes Ding.
Und guckt euch heute mal ein Smartphone an.
Das stimmt. Ja, das stimmt. Wir mussten halt noch relativ viel selbst machen. Das ist richtig.
Gerade weil wir halt schon aufgewachsen sind, zum größten Teil zumindest mit Computern, aber vieles da halt einfach noch nicht out of the box da war.
Erinnert sich noch irgendjemand an BNC-Netzwerke und Netzwerkkarten? BNC mit T-Stück und Terminator?
ja der kram hier
ott der fack moment moment es gab bnc auf tae dose
Ja, so ein Teil hatte ich damals auch.
Damals hat mich der Computerladen so hart gebetet wie noch nie.
Da habe ich mich bis heute noch nicht davon erholt, wie hart die mich gebetet haben, der Technikladen damals.
Ich wollte mir eine Netzwerkkarte kaufen für meinen Computer.
Also zwei Netzwerkkarten, Computer von einem Freund aus der Schule und meinem Computer.
Wir wollten dann Netzwerkzeug daheim bauen.
Und ich glaube, die Story habe ich euch schon mal erzählt.
Und der hat gesagt, also eigentlich fanden wir den Laden jetzt nicht sonderlich tolle.
Und er hat gemeint, doch, er hat hier zwei Netzwerkkarten.
Die sind aus der Raumfahrt, hat er uns erzählt.
Die sind mit Teilen aus der Raumfahrt.
So als hätte die NASA die Netzwerkkarten gebaut.
Und wir haben halt damals in dem Laden gestanden und gesagt,
oh, Netzwerkkarten aus der Raumfahrt, das muss das Beste sein, was es überhaupt gibt.
Und haben die Netzwerkkarten gekauft und das waren, die sahen ungefähr so aus wie diese Netzwerkkarten hier.
Mit, ähm, Aeon 45 und BNC-Stecker.
Und ich muss euch sagen, es war bis heute, legit, die beschissenste, schlechteste Netzwerkkarte,
die ich jemals hatte, die hat nie richtig funktioniert.
Dazu kam noch das Netzwerkeinstellen unter Windows damals, der der absolute Wahnsinn war.
Erinnert sich noch irgendjemand an Windows 95, Windows 98 Netzwerkeinstellung?
Du musstest damals in die Netzwerkumgebung gehen, NetBIOS einschalten, NetBUI einschalten, IPX ausschalten, TCPIP einschalten, in die richtigen Net...
Ich weiß noch was zum Teufel ist, NetBUI eigentlich.
das weiß ich bis heute nicht was das ist was ist das überhaupt dann gucken dass du in den
passenden settings die passenden häkchen gemacht hast ok net bo ist bestandteil des microsoft
portal auf der vermittlung ok alles o sie modell chat von wo aus es mit dem net bios
beziehungsweise mit dem LCC
was zum Teufel
ok heute macht man
IP einfach, sehr gut
irgendein Microsoft
Shit war das
das hat man damals, ja genau
diesen Mist und so musste man damals einstellen
genau und das hat man
gebraucht, dass in der Netzwerkumgebung
der Computer
also die anderen Computer
erschienen sind
es war so für arsch damals aber auf der anderen seite hat man damals halt noch vieles selbst
machen müssen und deswegen so eine so eine instinktives verständnis für technik kram
entwickelt ja und wisst ihr was das erste war also leute die damals dabei waren die werden
wissen wisst ihr was das erste war was oftmals auf so netzwerk veranstaltung
gemacht wurde damit es funktioniert weil es hat immer nicht funktioniert das war
das erste was gemacht wurde
das nicht
windows neu installiert endlich genau windows wurde neu installiert und und witzigerweise
hat das viel öfters als eigentlich hätte helfen dürfen geholfen windows neu installiert das
windows neu installiert war eigentlich so gut wie die ersten 12 stunden von jedem treffen mit
mehreren Computern hat eigentlich jeder Windows neu installiert.
Und das hat, wie gesagt, das hat viel öfters
funktioniert, als es eigentlich hätte funktionieren
dürfen.
Wie lange hat früher so eine Installation
gedauert?
Ich würde mal sagen, auch gar nicht so
viel länger als heute. Die Installation
selbst hat länger gebraucht, ja.
ich würde sagen so 25 minuten oder so hat die installation damals gebraucht von cd noch wenn
ihr glück hat es hat es ein computer der von cd booten konnte später konnten das an die meisten
von cd geboten zu 25 bis 30 minuten hast du installiert aber das ding war halt dass
der windows 98 installation nach der installation abgeschlossen war ja 25 30
minuten ja danach hat sie vielleicht noch der
netzwerktreiber oder so oder grafikkarten kann was installieren
musste aber dann ging es heute wirst ja nach der windows installation erst mal
für fünf minuten genervt mit welche sachen du ein und ausschalten willst und
ob du ortungsdienste einschalten willst und hast du nicht gesehen dann machst du
das erste mal programm auf da muss den standard browser auswählen dann geht
es auf und fragt dich ob du daten übertragen willst also ich würde sagen
der unterschied ist gar nicht mal so groß
dazu kommt dass er dann erstmals team installieren muss deine spiele
runterladen muss und so was das gab es damals nicht damals hast du nicht die
müssen spiele runtergeladen damals hat sie eine zweite festplatte wo die spiele
drauf waren und das war dann halt einfach da.
Das mag ich nicht.
Ja, es waren andere Zeiten.
Ich würde sagen, dass es potenziell heute
vielleicht ein Ticken schneller ist.
Aber
das hält sich in Grenzen. Also ich würde sagen,
Das hat gar nicht so viel länger gedauert damals.
Genau, das kommt ja noch dazu.
Half-Life plus Counter-Strike, das waren dann am Ende bloß, keine Ahnung, 2-3 Gigabyte oder so.
Und heute, wie viel hat Warzone? 150?
ist das nicht ist nein nein oder wir haben das ausspricht nicht dieses wo du also so
so möchte gern package manager von windows wo die hälfte nicht drin ist von dem was man haben will
Naja, Leute, also
Ich hatte einen echten Half-Life 1 CD-Key
Weil ich hab damals schon online gespielt
Und du konntest online spielen nur mit einem gültigen CD-Key
Du hast zwar im Internet damals
Gültige CD-Keys gefunden
Das waren aber nur welche, die dem Algorithmus nach gültig waren
die aber nicht für den Online-Service funktioniert haben.
Und wenn du einen Key gefunden hast, der mit einem Online-Service gültig war,
dann konnte damit immer nur einer gleichzeitig eingeloggt sein.
Das hatte ich wieder rausgeschmissen.
Also ich hatte meinen eigenen Half-Life 1 CD-Key.
Ich hatte das deutsche Half-Life mit Robotern.
Und das erste, was war, Half-Life installiert,
Plattpatch installiert, dass Half-Life 1 Original Half-Life 1 ist.
macht aber heute kaum einer dort installiert die modernen lieber neu runter
ja also ich muss sagen also ich glaube es gab kaum ein game was meine kreativität und
Bastler Drang damals so befriedigt hat wie Half-Life 1 mit dem Map Editor.
Worldcraft nannte sich das damals. Heute, also das ist das, was irgendwann mal zu
Hammer heißt der mittlerweile, oder? Editor.
Ja, Hammer. Früher hieß das Worldcraft. Half-Life ist das früher.
genau genauso so sei das damals aus wo man noch ziemlich gut erkennt dass half life 1 eigentlich
einen quickwatch als nein es ist übertrieben dass kein quickwatch das stimmt nicht auf quick engine
Basis ist.
Das war auch eine Zeit, wo es zum
guten Ton gehört, dass ein Spiel im Map Editor
dabei hat. Erinnert sich noch
einer an Command & Conquer Generals?
Wo du Singleplayer-Missionen im Map Editor
bauen konntest und sowas? Oder
muss ja nur mal an StarCraft denken.
Oder an WarCraft 3.
Ich glaube, es gibt keine
kein Game
mit Map Editor, was so
einflussreich war wie Warcraft 3.
Was da alles draus entstanden ist.
Auf lange Sicht.
Das war schon nice.
Uta Party
gab's da noch.
Also,
das war schon nice.
Tempest Rising?
Nee.
Das, ähm...
Gut, dass du sagst. Das hab ich in meiner Wishlist
drinne und wollte mir das kaufen,
sobald's rauskommt. Das ist jetzt rausgekommen
gestern oder so, gell? Nee.
Nee, nee, auf jeden Fall.
Das war's für mich.
Naja.
So, komm, ein Video gucken wir noch.
Ich krieg langsam echt Hunger.
Wobei, Leute, ich darf eigentlich keinen Hunger kriegen.
Ich hab einfach 500 oder fast 600 Kalorien
zusätzlich
Mandeln mit
Tiramisu-Geschmack, weiße Schokolade
und Vollmilch gefressen zum
Frühstück.
wieder nudel mit lachs heute korrekt heute gibt es nudel mit lachs eigentlich
dürfte ich aber noch überhaupt kein hunger haben viel zu viel gefuttert
weiß ich kenne die videos nicht taugt das was der in der live auf und das
gucken wir jetzt nicht das 22 min
how every agile sprint turns into a chaotic mess okay das ist kurz das kann
man noch kurz angucken
der blutzuckerspiegel lässt grüßen mein blutzuckerspiegel ist POG ist mein
blutzuckerspiegel absolut der ist
Was hab ich denn?
So ist mein Blutzuckerspiegel.
Ich hab vor paar Monate ein Blutbild.
Wurde gemacht.
Ja.
Und ich hab einen...
Moment jetzt. Nicht, dass ich Mist erzähle.
Wie heißt das?
Einen H2CA Wert.
Ne.
Äh. H. Moment.
Blutwerte. H2.
Ne. Äh. H.
H2A?
Ne.
Ähm.
Moment.
Wie hieß das Ding?
HBA1C.
Blutwerte.
Von 4,8.
4,8 ist absolut
POG-Wert.
Blutzucker.
Das ist quasi der Langzeit-
Blutzuckerwert über die letzten drei Monate.
Und über 6,5
hast du Diabetes.
Und ich habe 4,8. 4,8 ist ein
X, also wirklich
mit dem besten Wert, den man haben kann.
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob das hier irgendwie steht,
was gute Werte sind oder so.
Gibt es das vielleicht auch
Okay unter 6 einfach kein
4,8 das ist
Das ist sehr gut also egal wie viel
Ich fresse und wie viel Zucker und wie viel ungesunde
Ungesundes mein Blutzucker
Ist
Ich meine irgendwie ein Vorteil von man bewegt
Sich jetzt halbwegs viel muss es ja haben oder
ich meine, ich fresse viel
und ich fresse auch viel ungesund, aber ich bewege mich
wenigstens viel mittlerweile.
Guck mal, der Schreiker kennt
sich aus. Ja, den meinte ich.
Eigentlich sind generell meine Blutwerte
ziemlich gut.
Gibt eigentlich nichts.
Kann man ja mit 40 plus mal
gucken lassen.
So.
Agile.
Das einzige, was ein bisschen schlecht war,
war jetzt temporär,
Vitamin D war ein bisschen niedrig,
aber das ist im Winter eigentlich fast normal.
Beim letzten Mal gucken war das schon wieder normal.
Und ansonsten einschnicks.
Das weiß ich nicht,
ob das da dabei war.
ob ich männlich genug bin.
Keine Ahnung, ich glaube, das war nicht dabei.
So, also gucken wir uns mal an.
How every Agile Sprint turns into a Chaotic Mass.
Ist das bei euch denn überhaupt der Fall?
Also ich würde gar nicht sagen, dass das bei uns so sehr zutrifft.
bei uns ist es eher so
wir fangen an
mit einem Sprint
und irgendwann
mit einem Sprint wird der Sprint dann
refined
und man packt noch Sachen
dabei, weil man sich denkt, ey das brauchen
wir eigentlich jetzt
man könnte sagen, das ist super agile
aber es juckt auch keinen so richtig
wenn man es nicht hinkriegt, also
ich würde sagen, bei uns funktioniert das eigentlich noch ganz gut.
Ich nehme das mit.
Wir sind gerade dran, Leute.
Alter.
Erschreck mich nicht so.
In der Realität ist jeder agile Sprint ein unbekannten Dumpster-Fall.
Und irgendwie machen wir es nur immer wieder.
Deshalb dachte ich, dass ich einen Rant darüber machen sollte.
Also werden wir heute die fünf Phasen der üblichen agile Erfahrung diskutieren.
muss mal kurz in meinen Kalender schauen.
Alter,
iOS geht mir auch auf den Sack mit Updates installieren.
Moment, ich muss mal kurz das Handy von der Firma holen.
So, also.
Nächste Woche.
Nee.
Nächste Woche ist kein
Sprint Planning.
Das heißt, dass nächste Woche
eine ganz normale,
dafür übernächste Woche.
Genau, übernächste
Woche Dienstag.
Sprint Review.
Sprint Retrospektive.
Sprint
Planning.
Sprint Planning starts with a
realistic workload discussion, which
is corporate speak for let's cram an
entire month's worth of work into two weeks.
The product owner suggests an absurd list
of tasks. Developers give cautious
estimates and then management asks,
can you do it faster? A dev says,
this will take two weeks. The product
Und dann sagt der Scrum Master, der Optimist,
erinnere dich, Agile ist um Adaptabilität.
richtig funktioniert.
Da wird ja eine
Wissenschaft für sich draus gemacht mittlerweile.
Daily Stand-Up, ganz wichtig.
Wie sieht denn das aus bei euch?
Standet ihr beim Daily Stand-Up?
Beim Daily Scrum Stand-Up?
Steht ihr da wirklich oder heißt es einfach nur so
und jeder hockt rum?
Also bei meinem alten Arbeitgeber war das so,
Die haben gedacht, man muss da wirklich dafür stehen, dass das funktioniert. Beim neuen sitzen wir einfach ganz normal rum. Manche stehen, aber man muss sagen, bei meinem neuen Arbeitgeber funktioniert es besser als beim alten. Beim alten lief das Daily Scrum im Prinzip immer in ein, wer nichts sagt, hat auch nichts gemacht, artete das aus.
Was ja eigentlich genau der falsche Gedanke ist für sowas. Es müsste vollkommen okay sein, auch zu sagen, okay, ich habe jetzt eigentlich nichts Wichtiges zu berichten, es gibt jetzt auch nichts, was mich irgendwie aufhält oder mich irgendwie da blockiert beim Weitermachen. Heute habe ich nichts, nächster bitte.
So, es müsste eigentlich vollkommen okay sein, so ist das ja auch gedacht, dass das okay ist. Daily Scrum soll ja kein Wettbewerb sein, nur weil viel erzählt hat auch viel gemacht, leider und spätestens wenn da irgendwie Gruppenleiter, Teamleiter, Abteilungsleiter, Projektleiter, was auch immer dabei ist, dann artet das in gewisser Weise immer aus, weil die Leute wollen sich ja immer ein bisschen profilieren und denken sich, okay, ich muss jetzt auch den unbedeutendsten Shit,
mal zumindest fünf Minuten da irgendwie
auswalzen, damit jeder sieht, ey, gucke mal,
der macht ja auch was.
Und das ist eigentlich genau
so nicht gedacht.
Aber trotzdem passiert's.
So.
Der Manager hat ja da eigentlich gar nichts großartig drin zu suchen.
Weil nichts sagt, agil wie letzte Minute Chaos.
wo man von vorne rein wusste, da kommt nichts raus.
Die Retrospektive enthält bei uns das Gefühl, auch jedes Mal das Gleiche.
Aber hey, es ist immer noch besser als der Wasserfall. Wahrscheinlich.
Wenn ihr das Video genossen habt, dann lasst uns mal gucken.
der beste, der perfekte
Homeserver ist, auch für mich, aber
hat ja jeder so seine persönlichen
Präferenzen.
Schauen wir mal.
24 Minuten. Excellent.
Ihr wisst, bei mir dauert so ein Video mindestens
50...
mindestens 50 Minuten.
A perfect Homeserver
slash NAS that you can use for
virtualization. Also für mich ist schon mal
das perfekte NAS mittlerweile nicht mehr
Synology.
Sobald man quasi signierte Festplatten braucht.
Die Frage, wenn ich dieses Gehäuse und diese Backplane schon sehe, ist, ist es Hotswap-fähig?
Was meint ihr, ist es Hotswap-fähig?
Ich tendiere ja zu, es ist Hotswap-fähig, aber offiziell ist es nicht Hotswap-fähig.
Also ich meine, was ich damit sagen will ist, viele Sachen sind Hotswap fähig, aber sie
sagen offiziell nicht, dass sie Hotswap fähig sind, das heißt es kann auch mal sein, dass
es nicht funktioniert.
Also ich denke mal, die sind Hotswap fähig, aber offiziell nicht.
Das ist so meine Vermutung.
Doch, aber die wenigsten sagen offiziell ja, wir sind Hotswap fähig.
... DUCK Containers und wirklich alles was man denken kann.
Es wird mächtig, ruhig...
doch, ne? So ein
Mini-SAS zu 8x
SATA oder sowas.
Ne, Moment, das da hinten könnten ganz
normale SATA-Anschlüsse sein.
Das hier ist
eine Netzwerkkarte, würde ich mal vermuten.
Wahrscheinlich eine 10GB-Netzwerkkarte.
Ähm.
M.2 SSD.
Schönes
kompaktes Case, muss ich sagen.
Gibt's wenige
solcher Cases.
Es könnte auch sein,
dass es größer ist, als ich jetzt...
Ne, ne, ne, das ist ziemlich kompakt.
Was ich interessant finde, dass es ein normales
Netzteil ist.
Vor allem
so
angebaut. Das hat man
selten.
Ich kenne das unten drinnen, aber das
passt ja nicht und ich kenne solche kleinen Cases halt oftmals mit so kleinen, wie auch
immer, ja, nicht so normalen ATX Netzteilen.
Auf der anderen Seite, was ich auch vollkommen okay finde, ist externe Netzteile für solche
kleinen Dinger.
Ja, dass du hinten im Prinzip einfach nur so einen Hohlstecker oder wie die Dinger
heißt hast oder einen 24 volt netzteil drankommt bin ich versuche kleingram auch okay das braucht
gar nicht unbedingt netzteil innen drin aber schauen wir mal power efficient riesen wie
compact and easily upgradable and it's also going to have all the features that you respect from a
big boy ist es ein s rock mainboard easily upgradable and it's also going to have all
all the features that you would expect from a big boy capital S.
Ich habe mir nicht gedacht, vielleicht ist es so ein S-Rock Rack Mainboard.
Die machen auch ganz gute Dinger.
Schauen wir mal.
Including things like ECC Memory and Remote Management.
Moment, das Ding hat einen ILO oder besser gesagt ein,
wie heißt denn das bei Gigabyte?
Gilo?
also bei ibm heißt es erst bei hp heißt es wie hieß es noch mal bei dell
hieß das ja noch mal die ipad ist der überbegriff ein track track ist bei
dell genau ein track ja
Oder idrak, oder wie auch immer man das ausspricht, genau.
Erst mal Noctua-Lüfter rein, die teurer sind als der Rest.
Also, weiß ich nicht, aber...
Ich hab den Hang dazu, Noctua-Lüfter reinzubauen, die einfach viel zu teuer sind.
Wisst ihr, was ich mich immer frage? Wie geht das eigentlich?
Intel hat die letzten 10 Jahre, keine Ahnung, 25 neue Sockel.
AMD hatte die letzten Jahre zwei neue Sockel.
so wie ist das überhaupt möglich
das ist gut das ist gut wie ford ist dieses wir können pc express lot splitten in kleinere slots
oder riser card oder so das ist sehr praktisch weil die wenigsten die wenigste hardware braucht
wirklich 16-fach 16 Lanes, je nachdem was es ist. Da kannst du beispielsweise dann, wenn du das
splitten kannst mit einer Ryza-Karte oder so, kannst du beispielsweise dann eine 10-Gig-Karte
reinbauen plus einen SAS oder so Controller.
... und auf den G-Series-CPUs bekommst du auch integrierte Grafiken...
Das ist nice. Transcoding?
... die für Hardware-Video-Transcoding unterstützen.
Ja.
Auch wenn es nicht so gut ist wie die Intel-Grafiken.
Und da die M4 technisch eine Legacy-Plattform ist, sind die Teile sehr teuer
und wenn du die richtige CPU auswählen kannst, kannst du eine ziemlich effiziente Maschine mit der bauen.
Also fangen wir mit der richtigen CPU an.
Das ist die Ryzen 5 Pro 4650G.
Es ist eine 6-Core, 12-Thread-CPU mit integrierten Grafiken, die auf der Zen 2-Architektur basiert.
Ich habe die 4650G mitgebracht, weil sie eine ziemlich unvergleichbare Kombination von integrierten Grafiken
mit Unterstützung für Hardware-Videotranscoding,
eine reisende Preis-Kosten-Kosten-Kosten-Kosten
auf dem Reseller-Markt,
eine große Effizienz bei Idle,
wegen ihres monolithischen Designs,
und Unterstützung für unregisterte ECC-Memory.
Nun, als Pro-Serie-Sender,
Aber wäre mir wichtig jetzt.
Bei AliExpress muss man sich dann halt fragen, ob das wirklich ein Original-AMD-CPU ist.
Denn Zen 2, auf dem die 4. Gen G-Series Chips basiert, ist die erste Generation, in der AMD die Crash- und Idle-Bug-Bedienung festlegt, die die Zen 1 und Zen Plus Chips verursacht.
Am gleichen Zeit, wenn du nicht um die Power-Effizienz oder Videotranscoding interessierst, kannst du fast jede 3. Gen und neuere AM4 CPU benutzen, die du dir anbieten kannst.
Und keine Sorgen, du wirst immer noch die Video-Output von ihr bekommen, auch wenn sie keine integrierte Grafik hat.
Wie funktioniert das?
Lass mich dich zu unserem Motherboard vorstellen.
Das ist Gigabyte MC12LE0. Es ist ein Micro-ATX-Montenbord, basierend auf einem B550-Chipset, der mit sechs SATA-Porten, zwei PCI-E-Modulen und einem B550-Chipset verbaut ist.
waren keine irgendwelchen RGB-Dinger drauf oder irgendwelche Hitzeshields oder komplett
Metallverkleidung oder sowas in der Richtung.
Da waren Mainboards einfach...
...viereckige Platinen-Dinger mit vielen Komponenten drauf.
Ich finde, so mussten Mainboards aussehen.
...PCIe 4 Slots and an integrated BMC with support for web-based KVM...
Moment.
Diese Grafik und Optik, das kommt mir super bekannt vor.
Was ist denn da drunter?
Das ist irgend so ein...
Das sieht ein bisschen aus, dass das was, was die auch bei Piehole verwendet haben und sowas.
Das ist irgend so ein Dashboard Framework, was ganz viele verwenden.
Gerade so diese Kacheln hier mit diesen Farben und exakt die gleichen Farbtöne habe ich schon hundertmal gesehen.
S-Speed.
MegaRack, genau.
Das sind diese uralt Dinger.
sind es ist es schon ist es schon html5 oder immer noch java based team and has
its own internet boards it can be used to power your server on ok das ist schon
html5 da muss ich echt was sagen ey hut ab ich habe ja so einen so eine spider
kvm
so ein teil
habe ich mir mal bei ebay gekauft für keine ahnung 60 euro oder so damals
verwende ich auch regelmäßig noch ja das ist wirklich ein vga stecker ja im
endeffekt steckte das an den server dran oder an das gerät ran und hier steckte
netzwerk da kannst du per browser darauf so die preise sind komplett pp gar
zwischenzeitlich gab es die mal auf ebay für deutlich unter 100 100 100 euro
vielleicht soll ich nicht nach spider suchen
K vorn.
Oh!
Kickway, Alter!
Also ich hab die für 50 oder 60
Euro damals gekauft.
Zumindest, dieses Gerät
ist uralt.
Das wurde
hergestellt zuerst
oder so. Das ist wirklich
richtig alt.
ja, das ist richtig
richtig alt
und
ich weiß nicht, ob man das
hier irgendwo was sehen kann
von wann das
zuerst rausgekommen ist
vielleicht bei
Geizhals, wo man gucken kann, wann es
zuerst gelistet wurde oder so
Irgendwie so.
2013 und da war es schon da.
Guckt mal.
Also das ist ur, ur, ur alt,
dieses Ding. Das ist noch älter.
Und
ich hab mir das gekauft, bei Ebay
irgendein ausrangiertes Ding für 50,
60 Euro.
Und das war am Anfang, war das noch
java basiert und ich habe mir schon gedacht oh shit wenn es jetzt immer
schwieriger wird java im browser zum laufen zu bringen und so die tage von
diesem ding sind gezählt aber nein die supporten das ding immer noch
ok mittlerweile muss man sich einloggen okay aber es gab einen firmware update
was das ding html5 fähig gemacht hat nach 15 jahren oder so wo das produkt
raus ist. Das müsst ihr euch mal vorstellen.
Welcher Hersteller supportet
sein Kram 15 Jahre
mit Updates?
Das ist krass, oder?
Also da habe ich die sogar
auf Twitter mal gelobt.
Auf X.
ob ich das noch finde.
Ne, finde ich nicht mehr.
Ah, doch, hier.
Von 2022.
Ja.
Warum ist eigentlich
die Suche auf Twitter
so kacke?
Warte mal, X?
Man kann ja, wenn man nicht eingeloggt ist, nicht mal suchen, gell?
Alter, was ist denn...
Es ist so scheiße geworden, man, die Seite.
Die ist so dreckig schlecht
trotz Kacke geworden, Twitter, man.
Wie kann man so verkacken, Alter?
Egal.
zumindest habe ich mich 2022 drüber gefreut dass es noch eine firmware update gab
ja guck mal hier unten steht 2007 leute ich
wenn ich hier eingehört eingeloggt
wenn ich auch nicht eingeloggt oder
Shit.
Ich kann es euch jetzt nicht posten.
Ich habe es gefunden bei mir.
Zumindest, was neben dem Follow-Button
gibt es eine Suche?
Wo?
Ah.
Elon G-Baited.
Also mein Gerät ist von 2007, überlegt euch das mal, 15 Jahre.
Gab's da noch ein Update, also es ist nicht verkehrt.
So, aber jetzt gucken wir mal weiter.
Such mal nach Jetkey, das hab ich gesehen, das ist der mit dem Raspberry Pi drin, oder?
Ja.
F14 oder neuere, gibt es tatsächlich eine Option in der BIOS, die lässt Sie aktivieren,
die Integra...
am ende war es tot das längste bios update der welt quasi live auf reddit
ja
wo ist 24 stunden bios update hoher genau 100 stunden bios update finally ends an response system
Ja
Genau
100 Stunden BIOS Update
Sah von Anfang an schon ziemlich kaputt aus
F
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob sie das Ding danach wieder gefixt haben
Ja, haben dann Leute gesagt
So nach dem Motto
ja, können wir irgendwie was dran löten und so?
Ich bezweifle, dass man an solchen modernen Mainboards noch gescheit was dran löten kann.
Egal, schauen wir mal. Das Video fertig.
Ja, das ist Gigabyte. Gigabyte, also bestimmt nicht so schlecht überall.
Aber Gigabyte hat jetzt nicht unbedingt die schönste BIOS und auch nicht die schönste Software.
ich mein ich habe selbst ein gigabyte mainboard und so geil ist das jetzt nicht
und story shorts updating via die bmc interface doesn't work you have to do it through the shorts
update wer hätte ja auch denken können dass den button upload firmen firmware update auch
wirklich die firma updated das kann das das geht ja nicht wie hätte man auch damit rechnen können
dass das funktioniert. Fragt man sich natürlich dann hat es niemals jemand ausprobiert bei dem
Hersteller.
... via die BMC Interface doesn't work. You have to do it through the EFI...
Guck mal hier, easy, easy BIOS Refresh.
... interface doesn't work. You have to do it through the EFI Shell. I'll leave a link to a
guide that I wrote outlining all the steps... Heißt im Endeffekt USB Stick rein,
Nein, hau USB-Stick rein und...
Sekunde, lass mal kurz gucken.
Mainboard, eBay.
Na, ist schon ein bisschen teurer geworden, ha?
Nach dem Video.
Ist schon ein bisschen teurer geworden.
Das passiert ja meistens.
Meint das Video,
ist schon 5 Monate alt,
Keck, wait.
Sowas gibt's?
Habe ich noch nicht gesehen.
Nano KVM.
Ist das...
Zum Selbstbauen?
Oder ist das...
Das ist nicht zum Selbstbauen, aber das...
Gibt's fertig auf AliExpress?
Ja, ich hab gehört, dass angeblich durch diese ganze
Zollgeschichte
vermutet wird, dass
Waren aus China wieder
günstiger werden.
Das gucken wir uns mal an.
AliExpress.
Alter.
Anno KVM.
Naja.
Moment, 99 Cent?
Das ist wieder
G-Bait. Das ist AliExpress G-Bait.
In Wirklichkeit ist das teurer.
Ja, ist es auch. 7,72 Euro.
Aber ist trotzdem günstig.
Das funzt wirklich?
Warum kosten
5 denn 285 Euro?
Und, und...
What the f...
What? Das ist nur das Case, oder?
Das ist halt
Typisch AliExpress, wie du checkst halt mal nix.
Ja, 54 Euro, das erscheint mir doch...
Wie sieht's denn bei Amazon aus?
Aha!
Yuyito!
Gibt's das auch als...
Ein Schlag Granaten war schlecht zum ausprobieren.
Das ist sehr ordentlich, wenn man mal ein paar Sachen...
Der Kühler enthält ein kleines Werkzeug, um die Nuts auf dem Hintergrund des Motherboards zu schliessen.
Hier solltet ihr euch nicht verrückt machen und versucht nicht den Kühler zu übersteigen.
Für die Erinnerung werden wir den 16 GB Kit von Kingston aus dem unregisterten RAM verwenden.
Dieser Motherboard wurde bekannt, dass er ein wenig über den RAM furchtbar ist,
also wenn ihr das nicht wisst, schaut euch das QVL auf Digibyte's Webseite an.
mal ein bisschen weiter gucken. Aha, hier, Cases.
Das stimmt.
Ja, und vor allem ist bei diesem Kleinen
das Problem, dass selbst wenn du einen vollen
PCI Express Slot hast,
die halt oftmals nicht 16
Lanes haben, sondern
teilweise nur 4
oder so, oder 2, oder
ja.
Wisst ihr eigentlich, dass bei PCI Express
wirklich nur das vordere
Pflicht ist, im Endeffekt?
Also man kann eine
16, also man kann
eine 16
die Karte in einem PCI Express Slot betreiben, der nur vorne Kontakte hat.
Macht vielleicht nicht unbedingt Sinn, aber es müsste gehen.
Die einzige Ausgabe dieser Regelung, wenn es um Server-Builden zu handeln, sind Karten für irgendeinen Grund.
Es gibt viele wirklich gute Mini-ATX NAS-Karten, Fractal Node 304, Jonesbow N2 und N3, Silverstone
SST DS380 und viele der nicht genannten NAS-Karten, wie diese von Eolized.
Auf der anderen Seite gibt es space-optimierte Micro-ATX-Karten mit sechs plus Harddrive-Schlüsseln,
die ziemlich nicht existierend sind als Produktkategorie.
Most Micro-ATX NAS Cases in the market today are either so huge you might as well buy a tower case or limited to SFX or FlexATX Power Supply.
Ich mag das halt, wenn die so Wechselrahmen haben.
They are either so huge you might as well buy a tower case or limited to SFX or FlexATX Power Supply.
Mir gefällt sowas halt, wo du so Wechselrahmen für die Festplatten drinne hast.
SFX or FlexATX Power Supply.
Übrigens wisst ihr eigentlich, wie, was für eine akane, undurchsichtige Wissenschaft es ist, diese...
Moment.
Diese Sachen, wisst ihr, dass das so wirklich eine komplette Wissenschaft für sich ist?
Die LED-Ansteuerung von solchen NAS-Backplane-Wechselrahmen-Dingern.
weil, also wenn ihr die
professionelle
Ausführungen davon kennt, ja, guckt
mal zum Beispiel IBM Storage
Server, irgendwie sowas, wenn man
sich das mal, okay
gucken wir uns
den normalen Server von vorne an, genau
so, hier, so
wenn man sich sowas hier anguckt, da sieht man
wenn man das in einer ordentlichen Auflösung
bekommen würde
da sieht man
die Dinger haben vorne Lämpchen
sollten eigentlich Lämpchen haben.
Also Lämpchen für Aktivität und Lämpchen für Defekt.
In dem Fall sehe ich da nur ein Lämpchen.
Und diese Kommunikation
zu diesem Wechselrahmen,
also über die SATA oder SAS
oder was auch immer es ist, Backplane,
zu diesen LEDs, das ist eine komplett
wirre,
undurchsichtige Wissenschaft für sich.
Wenn du nicht ein fertiges System kaufst.
Dass du einfach nur leuchten lassen kannst,
welche Festplatte defekt ist. Das ist nahezu unmöglich.
Deswegen ist es auch gar nicht so einfach, wenn man sowas selbst baut, rauszubekommen,
welche Festplatte jetzt eigentlich defekt ist und welche ausgetauscht werden muss.
Die einfachste Variante ist tatsächlich, die Endungen von der Seriennummer mit einem Adding vorne drauf zu schreiben.
Dass du die Festplatte identifizieren kannst.
AliExpress Case.
Sie hat einen vollen ATX-Power-Supply und 8 3,5-Inch-Harddrives.
Es hat auch ein Dual-Chamber-Kühling-Design mit 4 Mounts für 4, 120mm Fans im Total,
4 vollen PCIe-Slots und all das hat eine ähnliche Fußgründe wie der Johns Bowen 4.
Es passt auch perfekt in meine TV-Schale.
Und übrigens, große Dank an Peter Brock für sein Video über den Johns Bowen 4 und den Sagittarius Case.
Das Case ist ein großer Kompromiss zwischen einem ITX-basierten NAS-Case mit bedingten
Features und Kühlung und einem großen Tower-Style-ATX-Case mit seiner, naja, Großheit.
Mein einziger Griff mit diesem Case ist...
Okay, ich gebe zu, es wäre cool, sowas zu haben, ich habe aber keinen Benutzzweck für.
Du meinst die Möglichkeit Festplatten auszutauschen bedeutet, dass du öfters kaputten Festplatten
hast. Also
im Prinzip ist das so ein bisschen so
Kopf in Sand stecken, dann geht auch nichts kaputt.
Ja, das ist logisch.
Ja, das werde ich eh
im Leben nicht bauen. Ich lasse mich mal kurz das
Case angucken.
Case AliExpress.
Toller geworden.
Ah ne.
Aber so eine Nano-KVM
finde ich schon mal ganz spannend.
Ernsthaft,
überlegen wir so etwas zu kaufen.
Einfach nur um zu gucken, wie es funktioniert.
Wie sieht denn dein
Server aus? Ich habe ein
seit
einer Weile
jetzt, habe ich so einen
P...
Ich habe keine Ahnung was für einen ich habe ehrlich gesagt, aber ich habe so ein Teil hier.
So ein Ding.
Nein, nicht sowas, so ein Teil hier.
Micro, HP Microserver, so ein Teil.
Ich weiß nicht welche Generation.
Aber so ein Ding habe ich schon seit einer Weile.
Ich muss ehrlich sagen, das macht seinen Job ganz gut.
Es hat auch keine Wechselrahmen
vorne von den Festplatten.
Ehrlich gesagt,
das Ding funktioniert ganz gut.
Ich habe bis jetzt, also ich habe da,
ich mache da auch sehr unregelmäßig
Firmware-Updates und sowas.
Mit ILO-Modulen, nö.
Ne.
Ich muss sagen, ich habe eh enorm zurückgeschraubt,
was
Hardware und so angeht.
Also, ich habe da zwei
SSDs drin und drei Festplatten,
wenn ich es jetzt richtig im Kopf habe.
Und
meine
Backup-Strategie
sieht vor, ich kopiere
per AirSync einmal nachts die wichtigsten
Sachen auf eine externe USB-Festplatte.
Das war's, das ist mein Backup.
und wisst ihr was, das reicht
man kann aus allem
eine hyperkomplizierte
Wissenschaft machen
und sicherlich findet man da auch genug Kritikpunkte
dran, was doch passieren könnte, wenn
aber
letztendlich 99% der Fälle
hast du damit abgefackelt
also ich hab mir so ein Ding hier
HP, Microserver.
Mal gucken, was die Dinger aktuell gerade kosten.
Oh, wow. Das ist aber teuer.
Ich guck mal kurz, was es bei mir gekostet hat.
Lass mal kurz mal. Ich glaube, ich hab's auch bei Amazon
gekauft.
Guck mal kurz. Orders.
Microserver.
Da könnt ihr auch gleich gucken, seit wann ich den hab.
Findet man nicht. Okay.
Vielleicht, wenn ich nach HP suche.
HP?
HP Microserver.
Generation 10 Plus.
Details.
Okay, habe ich seit dreieinhalb Jahren das Ding.
Ah, okay.
800 Euro.
War nicht billig damals, ja.
Nein, das mache ich nicht.
Die App habe ich noch nie großartig verwendet.
Die habe ich auch nie fertig entwickelt.
Das war einfach nur mal so ein Versuch.
Wie könnte man das machen mit Tracking-Nummern aus E-Mails?
Verwende ich nicht.
Verwende ich nicht mehr.
Das war aber eine coole Idee.
Aber ich gehe davon aus,
da gibt es mittlerweile bessere Apps,
die das gleiche machen wie meine.
Nämlich aus E-Mails Tracking-Nummern extrahieren können.
Gibt es bestimmt was besseres als das, was ich gestrickt habe.
Was willst du dir kaufen?
Ein Asus WS6?
Sage?
Was für ein Ding?
Moment, das habe ich ja ewig nicht gesehen.
Ein Bond mit zwei CPU-Sockel.
Das habe ich ja ewig, das habe ich bestimmt 15 Jahre nicht mehr gesehen.
Ich dachte, das ist komplett out mittlerweile sowas.
Weil eine CPU auch schon genug Kerne hat.
Früher war das gang und gäbe.
So.
2007, 8, 9, 10, 11, 12 vielleicht.
noch daten server systeme oftmals dual zockel boards aber das habe ich ja ewig
nicht mehr gesehen mainboards mit dual zockel wusste ich gar nicht dass es noch
gibt
aber aber hauptsache mit tossling anschließend dass er das ist davon den
anschluss in erden workstation board als ein server board oder was ist was hat was sind das
was sind das für socke intel c 621 ich habe keine ahnung was das ist sockel 36 47 ddr 4 ist auf
jeden fall ein bisschen ältere plattform schon ich habe keine ahnung was 3 was 36 47 für einen sockel
2017 ja interessant dass es das überhaupt noch gibt wie gesagt mainboards mit dual
sockel habe ich ewig wirklich bestimmt seit 2010 oder so nicht mehr gesehen
warum willst du dir sowas kaufen
also was ist der anwendungszweck von 2017 verbraucht wahrscheinlich auch ziemlich
ordentlich strom virtualisierung okay aber warum ein dual sokel board erreichen die
aktuelle CPUs mit 24 kern nicht oder oder weil es geht weil es geht ist
natürlich auch eine Sache die lasse ich immer gelten
Man vieles ist spannend einfach weil es geht ja
Ich bin einem sockel teurer als mit zwei sockeln ok
Ich hätte jetzt eher gedacht andersrum
der wahrscheinlich weil kaum einer dual sockel mainboards kauft
streamst du eigentlich aus einer windows vm raus mein obs läuft auf windows und
mein linux läuft in der form guck hier bei linux das ist das ist quasi eine form zeige
ich dir hier auf dem zweiten desktop hier siehst das ist bloß immer fullscreen jetzt gehe ich mal
aus dem fullscreen raus hier also mein das ist mein windows wenn das ist das haus system da
läuft alles drauf da läuft man video kabel drauf beim streaming rahmen die ganzen games und wenn
ich irgendwas bastelmäßiges mache mache ich das hier aus der linux vm raus die linux vm ist auch
ordentlich bestückt ja die hat aber soll ich an 8 cpu kerner hat 24 g gramm also
hardware mäßig hat meine vor allem wahrscheinlich mehr als viele voll
vollständige desktop pc ist ja doch keine performance probleme das einzige
wofür die vm nicht gut ist ist natürlich alles wo du hardware unterstützung für
brauchst ja also 3d sachen laufen mehr schlecht als recht drin aber also
gerade ältere aber was halt nicht gut geht ist da drin beispielsweise in der
vm 4k videos gucken weil eben kein hardware video decoder da drin hast das
ist was da könnte vor allem wer echt mal was machen aber man hat keinen bock mehr
an vor allem bei workstation groß zu entwickeln habe ich den eindruck
wie viele number of processors und number of course per
prozessor 8 also number of processors einer number of course 8
ja und das hier habe ich gesetzt dass ich nested virtualisierung machen
könnte wenn ich will also vor allem in der form
ich würde nicht sagen dass das product ist vor allem bei workstation wird er
noch weiterentwickelt aber sehr lahm und da kommt kaum noch was
ja genau als warum es die settings überhaupt gibt weil sie nicht genau wahrscheinlich wegen
oracle lizenzbedingungen im zweifelsfall ist so sachen immer wegen oracle lizenzbedingungen
aber wer betreibt oracle sachen in vorüber wachstum eigentlich keiner
okay leute glaube ich gehe jetzt mein lachs mit nudel aufwärmen ich habe zwar 560 kalorien und
morgen extra noch reingestopft aber mittagessen geht trotzdem und dann gehe ich schon runde
fahrrad fahren mit meinem borgers bike
ich bin immer noch am überlegen leute entweder gehe ich heute eine ordentliche
lange runde rennen so 13 14 kilometer oder ich gehe wirklich mal schön 23
stunden runde fahrrad fahren glaube ich hier meine runde fahrradfahrt ich war
gestern rennen gestern relativ viel laufen ich merke ich merke es noch so richtig im
schienbein fahr ich lieber eine runde fahrrad dadurch dass ich letzter zeit nicht mehr so viel
fahrrad gefahren bemerkt ist halt relativ schnell am pommes so nach 30 kilometern tut mir der arsch
schwer hast du mittlerweile durch sport abgenommen die letzten jahre ich habe enorm viel abgenommen
die letzten jahre ich würde aber nicht unbedingt sagen dass es hauptsächlich durch den sport
gekommen ist sondern eher durch weniger futtern insgesamt mittlerweile ist es so dass es ungefähr
gleich bleibt ich fresse wieder ordentlich aber ich bewege mich halt auch viel mehr also dass
mein Peak-Gewicht
war 108,5
und jetzt wiege ich so 82 Kilo.
So ungefähr. Also ich habe
ungefähr 26 Kilo abgenommen.
Und es hält sich jetzt auch plus minus
immer so 1-2 Kilo.
Ich fresse wieder ganz normal
ordentlich viel und alles, aber ich bewege
mich jetzt halt auch relativ viel.
Deswegen werde ich nicht wirklich
dünner, so minimal ein bisschen.
ja also ich habe die letzten jahre wo ich sie letztlich machen 2023 jetzt mehr
mehr sport da habe ich noch mal insgesamt habe ich da schon noch zu 34
kilo vielleicht oder sammler vielleicht noch mal fünf kilo abgenommen insgesamt
aber es geht halt viel langsamer und wie heißt dieses sprichwort you can never
outrun your diet oder so ähnlich ich bin 174 groß
Ja.
Okay, Leute.
Dann geh ich jetzt auf.
Geh was futtern.
Ordentlich Nudel.
Sich mit Nudel vollpumpen
vor einer größeren Fahrradrunde
ist immer eine gute Idee.
Dann mach ich noch so eine halbe Stunde
Pause und dann so
14 Uhr oder so, würde ich sagen, fahr ich los.
dann bin ich bin ich so bis 17 uhr wieder da
alles klar also was für ein fahrrad habe nun das haben wir schnell beantwortet mach
mal ausrufezeichen bike im chat mit lachs nudeln mit lachs oder ja genau
ausrufezeichen bei kate dass da mein fahrrad guckt da
das genau so sieht's aus das einzige was ich daran geändert habe ist ich habe eine größere
kassette hinten drauf gemacht dass sie ein bisschen einfacher die berge hochkommen ich
habe jetzt hinten glaube ich ich glaube standardmäßig sind 34 zähne 11 bis 34 und
ich habe 11 bis 40 drauf wenn ich jetzt nicht ganz falsch liege das ist eigentlich außerhalb
leicht außerhalb der spezifikationen aber es funktioniert trotzdem ohne probleme keine
schutzbleche es ist warm und trocken draußen da spritzt nichts im regen möchte ich damit nicht
unbedingt durch regen und matsch möchte ich damit nicht unbedingt fahren ja dann spritzt das auch
also regen und matsch ich bin auch schon durch regen und matsch gefahren
der spritz aber heute ist regen und matsch nicht angesagt
und ich kann euch sagen ohne scheiß elektrische schaltung richtig nice habe
ich auch immer gesagt so ein scheiß verbrauchten das aber seitdem ich elektrische schaltung habe
will ich immer elektrische Schaltung haben.
Also ich meine, die Schaltung,
das muss man sagen, selbstverständlich ist
eine Schaltung immer mechanisch.
Aber wie die Schaltung angesteuert wird,
ist halt die Sache.
Die wird elektronisch angesteuert und nicht mal, wie man das
kennt von früher, wo hier so ein Seilzug
quasi durchs Fahrrad lief.
Da ist eben hier
im Sattel
ist eine Batterie
und hier ist intern halt ein Kabel verlegt
bis zu den Schaltdingern
und das geht halt über so ein
elektronisches bussystem das heißt du musst dann auch keine spannung mehr einstellen und
sowas an der schaltung und so was ist halt einfach sehr direkt und schnell ja wenn du
akku leer hast ist doof dann kannst du nicht mehr schalten aber das warnt dich vorher und
das lebt die letzte aktion was es macht ist auf so einen semi einfachen gang schalten und dann
nicht mehr funktionieren nein das hält das hält ja fast so eine batterie ladung
man kann das mit seinem garmin fahrradcomputer oder mit irgendeinem
x-beliebigen fahrradcomputer koppeln und sieht dann auch die batterie der
batterie stand also da muss man sich keine gedanken machen dass man da das
irgendwie übersieht also ich habe meins geladen vor einem dreiviertel jahr oder
so und das ist immer noch klopp auf 70 prozent oder so aber gut bin jetzt auch
wenig gefahren in letztes über den winter
so alles da leute ich gehe jetzt pippo fett futtern mag ich fahrradfahren bis
Seid macht's gut.
See you.